ladies and gentlemen we have very
serious news tonight
dr fauci has come out and essentially
lit a fire under lab leak hypothesis
this is very important news we must talk
about
instead we're going to lead with don
lemon did a failed publicity stunt
pretending he was quitting cnn because
his ratings are down
77 and we and we talked about i was like
i don't know this this fouchy thing's
really seriousness
and we're all like we should make fun of
don lemon like yeah it's true we should
make fun of don lemon
so joining us to make fun of don lemon
is chris barron
not of the spin doctor not of the spin
doctors i'm not that guy no but uh
introduce yourself yeah hi i'm chris
barron i'm the president of return
strategies i'm a contributor to human
events and the political insider
and apparently the spin doctor's guy
isn't a fan no he's not because people
jump into his like timeline on twitter
and you know bring up trump and stuff
he's like i'm not that guy
which i point out to him that's never
happened to me no spin doctors fans have
ever jumped into my timelines
do people really tweet at them though or
no they really do really cause you could
well follow the tweet chain back up is
it is it because his twit twitter is
like at chris barron or something it is
that's why i'm at chris r baron because
he stole chris barron like
there can be only one right a jet match
that's it highlander all right man
thanks for hanging out and we got you
what's up everybody good to be here
thank you oh yeah i'm here as well i'm
pushing buttons in the corner it's gonna
be a really fun night i cannot wait to
make fun of don lemon like
we have other you know whatever really
important news i mean a federal judge
ruled that joe biden's policies are
basically racist
well uh as much as i'll say it's making
fun of lemon i really do think
the media is one of the biggest it's
like the biggest root of the problem or
at least one
large root providing nutrients to this
corrupted political infra you know
ecosystem and infrastructure so
we definitely got to talk about how
desperate they are
and it's good news it's a bit more
optimistic than all the bad news but
before we get started my friends
we have a really awesome sponsor tonight
virtual shield sponsors the show
check out surfing internet safe the link
is in the
in the description below and you can get
50
off for life they actually even say at
the bottom that you can enjoy 24 months
of online security
and that's over 77 off if you get it for
59.88 it's only 2.50
a month you can just click that button
sign up for free now for those that are
wondering what it is it's a virtual
private network so a lot of people have
started working remotely
for the past year if you've been at home
a virtual private network is a basic
layer of security
it makes it harder for hackers and
criminals and big corporations in the
government to track what you're doing
i always describe it like this you live
in a house probably you don't expect
people to break in
but you still lock your doors in windows
but let's be real like if somebody
wanted to kick your door or window and
they probably find a way but you want to
maintain that basic level of security
that's what a vpn is it'll help keep you
safe on the internet
because facebook and all these big
corporations they track every little bit
of data vpns are legit and virtual
shield they've been a sponsor of my work
since my first youtube channel so
they're incredibly awesome and i'm
eternally grateful again
go to surfinginternetsafe.com and they
have it right there
50 off for life only two dollars and 50
cents per month if you want to take your
security seriously
and i recommend you do because it's a
very simple and easy layer of security
you get a program
you press go boom you're done ready to
go there's a bunch of other perks and
benefits
i'm not going to mention because youtube
probably won't want me to but
you should read into it because there's
cool stuff that ian's like yeah yes
like the cool things that vpns can do
for you that i probably can't say
because youtube will be like whoa
uh i'll just leave it there check it out
it's basic security it's awesome
and don't forget go to timcast.com click
that blue members only button and sign
up
because we will have an exclusive
members only bonus segment
up tonight but there's also a really fun
segment we did last week
which apparently got a lot of comments
about the trump time traveling
conspiracy theory
which because we're buzzkills we debunk
but you know well i should say debunk
with quotes because we're just giving
our opinions on
conspiracy theories i don't know how you
actually like go to the future to claim
it's not true or whatever but the point
is
it's fun go check it out now without
further ado
making fun of don lemon yes here's the
story from fox news
don lemon continues to lose viewers
even after rebranding cnn show desperate
publicity stunt the cnn anchor has lost
a whopping 77 percent of viewers
since the first week in january now when
i heard the story
you may you may have heard this don
lemon apparently made some announcement
that he was
grateful for all his years at cnn and he
was going to be you know
changes were coming and everybody was
tweeting i saw everybody tweeting don
lemon's quitting it's over the show's
done
his ratings have dropped so dramatically
surely they have fired the man
turns out it was a publicity stunt where
he's like here's what look as a quote i
appreciate all the years of cnn
tonight with don lemon but changes are
coming and i will fill you in
and then all they did was they changed
the name of his show
from cnn tonight with don lemon to don
lemon tonight
that's it same time slot same times a
lot same everything same everything
i mean honestly is there a point where
cnn just recognizes that they're
basically parody
at this point this is this is something
that someone on our this is like a
babylon b
article this is something someone on our
side would spoof
say you know this is how ridiculous cnn
we don't have to worry about that
because cnn is actually
they're doing it themselves didn't
babylon b write an article saying that
like cnn was beating them at their own
game
it was something like that no but but
that's what what's really funny about
the satirical articles like babylon b
the onion writes really over the top
nonsense
like one of my favorites is uh stress of
the presidency ages joe biden 10 years
and it's a corpse just like a like a
mummified corpse
because he's already almost 80 years old
that's that's a that's real dark humor
but
it's very silly right bevel and b has
their silly articles
but they'll also write things like cnn
you know
beats wins award to beat babylon be at
parity or something
and the funny thing about babylon b is
it's it's a higher brow humor
oh yeah and people fall for it i think i
want to try and find it
if there's that uh let's see if i can
find the babylon b cnn
competition i don't even know what to
look for but i'm pretty sure they did
that
well and you know there's been all of
this like pushback against babylon b
people saying like oh you know
politifact rating that oh this is not
true you know this is a debunked thing
i mean it should speak about the state
of the modern democratic party and the
left
that people easily confuse obvious
parity
with the actual policies of the left you
know like
to be fair i've seen people confuse
uh like the onion for real news too
yeah but babylon b is is very political
and there are a lot of people who think
who fall for it
so here's the article in major deal the
babylon b purchases competing satire
site
cnn and it shows the babylon b logo next
to the cnn logo
so good this is this is beyond parody i
don't know if we can
maybe i can play this let's let's try
and play it
there we go earlier i told you i had an
announcement
and i do it's been really really great
this is the last night that we'll be cnn
tonight with don lemon
so i appreciate all the years of cnn
tonight with don lemon
um but changes are coming and i will
fill you in
but until then i am very proud of my cnn
special about marvin gaye's
groundhog all right all right you get it
the dude was very obviously trying to
make it seem like he was quitting
right wow well it's good news
but no and by the way like is was
anybody more disappointed that trump
lost than the executives at cnn
yeah they were hurt the worst absolutely
you know what they built their entire
brand around
we hate trump more than anybody else
msnbc did as well
so i just watched the deep impact you
ever see that movie no
have whitian's laughing no no i've seen
i've seen the clips from it
armageddon was clearly the better movie
so you do you know what twin films
is so like this is weird that happens
where
they keep they make two movies of the
same movie at the same time
so like a good example would be a bug's
life and like ants
is this kind of like when in uh r b or
hip-hop in the 90s where they did whoop
there it is and then like hoot there it
is like the same thing yeah something
like that yeah
so they made armageddon asked you know a
bunch of guys got to go to an asteroid
blow-up
and they made deep impact batman's got
to go to a comic comet and then blow it
up
uh in that movie because i don't want to
lose my train of thought
the main character works for msnbc and
she's trying to do a legitimate story
like the movie starts spoiler alerts for
those that haven't seen a 20 23 year old
movie
so she works for msnbc she thinks she's
got a story about the president having
an affair with a woman named ellie
msnbc investigative reporting
in the same story amazing right yeah
today
so but it was interesting because i'm i
i watched armageddon
which is this really silly movie where
these like oil rig guys go to an
asteroid it makes no sense but it's
it's it's ridiculous silliness deep
impact tries to be much more serious
we're like we got to go to this comment
and blow it up
and i'm like i'm watching the beginning
and i see this woman she's like i work
for msnbc and a camera guy comes out and
they're like we're going to get this
report on the president and expose him
i'm like wow is that what msnbc used to
be right were they like real news at
some point i don't remember them being
no there was
there was a there was a time where msnbc
was kind of positioned as the
almost a right of center news
organization like
way back in the day wow yeah i know like
that's it seems amazing by the way
the reason why cnn's been hurt more than
msnbc
is because i hate both of them equally
but msnbc has leaned into
actually some kind of entertaining
personalities like i mean i think rachel
maddow's a buffoon
but she's good at her job when she cried
when the mueller report
she well she almost cried when the
mueller report was like
was bunk right like trump wasn't a
russian asset you could see her like
welling up like
well this is it that no
no got you know rachel maddow they've
got joy reid like i can't believe that
woman still
has a job they've leaned into these kind
of like bigger personalities
whereas cnn's got chris cuomo and don
lemon and brian stelter and essie cup i
mean it's like
you know i mean obviously if you're
gonna if you're a a
left winger and it's post trump if
you're gonna watch anything
it seems like msnbc a little more
entertaining to watch than cnn you know
what it feels like
could you imagine going to a circus like
imagine there's two circuses
and in one there's a bunch of clowns
going we are not clowns
do not laugh at us and you go on the
other one like we're totally clowns have
a good time
yeah that's msnbc yes they like they're
totally 100
yeah cnn is trying to make you think
they're like imagine a bunch of clowns
wearing like suits
but they're still in their clown makeup
and they're trying to act like they're
doing reporting
you're like guys okay this doesn't work
well and it's like the contrast doesn't
work either
like you know they've got those people
like wolf blitzer and john king or
supposed to be like these hard news
people
and they're on a cr i mean essentially
like a crazy conspiracy
hoax filled television you know what i
mean like it's like it doesn't it
doesn't work meanwhile like
msnbc is going with joy reid like she's
just everybody knows she's not like
they're not even trying
you look at what don lemon did with that
audio clip very clearly
making it seem like he was quitting in a
desperate bid you know you know that
happened i bet
they were like don your your ratings are
down 77
like nobody's watching and he was like
well maybe people don't know it's my
show
maybe people need to know it's don lemon
you're right let's change the name from
cnn tonight with don lemon to
don lemon tonight yeah like that's their
big play yep
uh okay that's you know okay i forgot
where i was going before but
clearly the strategy makes no sense the
ratings are in the gutter and that was
what they thought
was going to attract people well i mean
but again they built an entire brand
around trump i mean no one was watching
cnn before trump you go back and you
look at the ratings pre-trump
cnn's ratings were absolutely in the in
the garbage i mean they were they were
absolutely terrible because
to their credit for a few years cnn
tried to be this place somewhere in
between
fox news and msnbc and they realized and
increasingly polarized society
there was no room to kind of be the
middle guy so instead they just went
dove all in you know into hating trump
you mentioned this we were talking about
satire that it says something when
snopes needs to constantly debunk the
babylon b
about cnn's type you know audience
here's what happens tucker carlson
his writings went down for sure it still
is it like three million or whatever in
the key demo he's still
i think he's in the high you know six
fig six figures
so everybody's ratings took a hit
literally everybody so for obvious
reasons i mean you had this massive
election
everybody's gonna go down but msnbc and
cnn went down
more than like all the other networks
more than all the youtube channels i
mean a lot of people
on youtube and podcasts are doing better
ratings are going up
so what happened was tucker
for instance he's he's the highest rated
because i for one i think he's a smart
guy i think he's a really good job
and as for the other cnn personalities
fox is like an oasis in a desert you can
go to any one of these networks nbc abc
whatever and and hear the same
garbled nonsense one of my favorite
examples of how garbo the nonsense was
is
during the the the mueller no no this is
the ukraine stuff
gordon sandlin that's his name right
sunderland yeah
he had said that trump said no quid pro
quo
but he thinks trump wanted it what did
fox news say
quote sandlin quote no quid pro quo
literally a quote
i can accept that whether you infer
something else from it every other
network
sondlin confirms quid pro quo so so
so fox is this oasis in the desert for
people they want to watch something they
know
cnn and msnbc leaned in as hard as they
could into building
a a network off of people who hate trump
that won't last once trump is gone it
says a lot about the two different
culture war
you know parent bubbles whatever they're
you know smaller bubbles are libertarian
conservative whatever versus like
leftist liberal
the the liberal voters only cared about
hating trump
and that's the only thing that kept them
together as a voting block and that
that's why
this honeymoon is going to be so quick
for joe biden because the sad reality
for him is
is there's no cohesive policy like group
behind him like whether you love trump
or hated trump
trump in 2017 when he got inaugurated
people knew what it was trump for
he was for building a wall you know he
was for negotiating new
trade deals he was for making america
great again
all of these things he was for biden
voters only cared about one thing
i hate trump and so now you're seeing
all these
internal divisions with the democratic
party over actual policy stuff
and realizing they have no cohesive
argument because their entire election
was predicated on simply hating trump
now let's talk about the leftists hey
i'm getting some
some feedback that the audio is very low
very low we're having some problems with
audio guys we just had an audio
technician in today so
we're kind of working with the new setup
um some people are saying that you're
coming in too quiet maybe to turn the
gain up other people are suggesting to
refresh your stream
and that might fix it on your end yeah
because on our end
the uh the mixer shows that it's coming
in normally yeah i've seen a flood of
comments in the chat talking about the
audio
i'm seeing about 50 50 people saying
it's fine and people saying it's low it
could be one of those things you just
need to get used to
as well but yeah we are tweaking it yeah
refreshing for sure yeah we can uh you
can turn the master up
yeah you do that with the gain someone
suggested turning up the game
how's that oh that's louder is that a
lot louder
yeah i can turn everybody down a little
bit well we're
actually turn that way down that might
help yeah there we go all right we'll
get there we'll get there
well we'll have we'll have to i
apologize for everybody we'll have to uh
sort it because we are trying to get the
audio fixed and
i don't know it's just uh you have to do
it in order to hear the audio and then
get the feedback to fix it so yeah
everybody was everyone was complaining
before that we had like our audio levels
would you would like fluctuate
and so we're like we got to get someone
to come in and standardize it and so now
people are probably like noticing the
audio is different
it's just great it looks like you fixed
it wow and the comments are coming in
yeah it sounds better
i didn't really do anything just tweaked
it a little bit yeah such a minor thing
i i did what i could while we appreciate
i hope this works for you guys
we got it type one if it sounds great in
chat there you go perfect
anyway back to what we were talking
about let's talk about uh the leftists
because
believe it or not there's a difference
between liberals and leftists and a lot
of people don't really differentiate and
i think it's because
liberals and leftists voted together and
now that trump's gone they're not going
to
but here's you you hate to see it oh
these poor
young 20-something dsa types
a lot of these people who are democratic
socialists
this is their first foray into politics
they're in their early twenties
you know we've had some people here on
the show and you know i'll be talking to
them and also
these leftists and i'll say you know
look during the obama era you had with
occupy wall street blah blah i'll say a
bunch of things and they'll go
i was 10 and i'm like you were 10 years
old
like yeah so i have no idea what that is
i'm like okay
so they they come into this thinking
joe biden is their path towards getting
what they want not realizing
that's not true it's never been true
it's been 50 years
but they have no political experience
but they can't vote so what do we get
now
over from cnbc student debt forgiveness
isn't
in biden's annual budget here's why
experts say that's not surprising
well this expert says that's not
surprising because biden is duplicitous
and the democrats lie in order to get
elected not like republicans don't but
democrats do it
so all of these young dsa people thought
they were going to get student loan
forgiveness
they were like we want fifty thousand
dollars and then biden was like yeah
okay we'll do it and they voted for him
and then he's like well we'll probably
just do ten thousand dollars
and then he's like now we're getting
nothing well by the way do these young
dsa types think that like cindy mccain
and all the establishment republicans
who couldn't vote for trump and were
voting for biden
do you think they were voting for that
agenda no
no absolutely not this is this is not
surprising to anybody who's been paying
attention
well we all know that bill crystal is a
huge fan of student debt forgiveness
and joe walsh and adam kinzinger and all
of these other rhinos
they vote democrat all the time because
conservatives
became socialists or is it because the
establishment is the party of the ultra
wealthy and they're going to
sell you out to gain political power and
hey you don't get to like trump
but at least trump was like a molotov
cocktail in the system
by the way look i'm not i'm a fan of
bernie sanders and i'm a fan of bernie
sanders policies but the one thing i'll
appreciate about bernie sanders
is i actually think he believes in what
he says now i think most of that stuff
is completely insane
but i respect the fact that he actually
will walk the walk
i don't think so i used to think that i
used to be a fan of bernie back in
2015-16
and then uh i he just started
flip-flopping
you know so he went up on stage the one
of the most famous moments and he said
if you're white you don't know what it's
like to be poor
okay that's a weird departure from where
bernie used to be when he was like
fighting for unions in the working class
now he's
espousing woke garbage that makes no
sense
and he endorsed hillary clinton and i'm
like ah okay he's got no spine
you know bernie might might you know
believe these things but a jellyfish
with good ideas is still a jellyfish
then i'm not going to vote for it
no and i'm look i'm not saying the the
dsa types would have been disappointed
with bernie because bernie would have
run a campaign that would have been
trying to attract those suburban
women voters who just couldn't bring
themselves to voting for donald trump
um which by the way i'm proposing a
constitutional amendment that suburban
women can no longer
vote yes actually it would automatically
suburban women only suburban women it
would fix both
both parties will be fixed immediately
so it's so it's not as as
as what is it the 19th it's not quite
yeah it's not as extreme as when people
say
but if you're just just if you're
getting your political opinions by
watching bravo like if that
like it's fine fine watch bravo but if
that if that's where you're getting your
political opinions from i think you
really shouldn't be voting
i mean you know i i've been thinking
about quite a bit are you familiar with
the starship
starship troopers so we've brought that
up a lot service guarantees citizenship
and i used to be like no people need to
vote but the democrats go too far with
it right they want
everyone to be able to like sit in there
sit in their chairs eyes half open
and then a guy drops a letter on their
on their chest and they go they just
stamp and then they hand it back like
there's got to be some effort involved
but now the more that i think about it
i'm like there's got to be some skin in
the game for voting
because what happens is people will move
into you know a city they'll live in new
york new york falls to crap
so they'll move somewhere where it's
nice vote for crap it falls to crap and
they leave again
you effectively have a group of people
that act like you know they go from
place to place
destroying it and then leaving and then
it's really difficult to repair things
politically like most machines it's
really easy to break it's really hard to
fix
well and fundamentally you'd think this
would be easy i mean if you're leaving
new jersey in new york because you hate
new jersey and new york
i mean it's not because you suddenly
decided that you can't stand the weather
anymore
or that you you don't like the corner
deli it's because you hate the way that
the state's been run into the ground
so yeah move to texas if you want but
don't vote for the same kind of
politicians
who ruined new york and that's what
we're seeing all across the
the country every one of these censuses
where they're showing like oh well
north carolina's adding people florida's
adding people georgia's adding people it
makes me nervous
because they're not moving from west
virginia you know well people people are
leaving west virginia
right yeah right yeah they they lost a
ton of of uh
is that a good thing i think it might be
a good thing
as long as it i mean i don't who are the
kind so so i read this story from i
think it was the ap and it was like
west virginia saw the biggest exodus of
any state yes and i was reading and
people were saying like i'm sick of
being in this place where they just want
guns and i'm like those people are
leaving
that's good news though i'll say this
about west virginia and i told you i
live
a mile from west virginia i walk into
west virginia from my backyard um
i think it's interesting when you find
these enclaves of like progressivism
in a place like west virginia they
realize they have to live
with their neighbors they realize that
they're vastly outnumbered
like conservatives are tolerant of
liberals that they
disagree with you know you go to harpers
ferry you go to berkeley springs you go
to
thomas west virginia or davis there's
all kinds of little enclaves of
progressivism
and it's completely and totally accepted
by the conservatives who run the state
yeah
go to places like dc and try to walk
around with a make america great again
hat on like it ain't gonna happen well
this is this is actually a problem
conservatives have they the the
they're unfortunately too tolerant yeah
that's and that's true
the democrats will try and claim that
the republicans are fascists and racist
and i'm like
i don't know what you're talking about
like i see these memes from the left
where they're like republicans
they'll lie cheat and steal to gain
power and i'm like they haven't had any
power and
how long and they just don't do anything
and they won't do those things
look nancy pelosi will use whatever
tools are available to her
even if they cross the line even if
they're an abusive power i mean look
her deciding to to strip the committee
assignments from marjory taylor-greene
for things that she said not since she
was in congress but things that she said
before she got elected
the voters who elected her knew what she
said and the democrats decide to take
you know to strip over committee
assignments if a republican did that
people be up and armed no republican
would ever do that what if a democrat
said offensive things
while they were in congress like i don't
know ilhan omar ilhan omar
or maxine waters who's been pushing
crazy conspiracy theories for decades
republicans are
are too weak man the republican
politicians they're they're
i don't remember who said this but
they're more concerned about the opinion
of the new york times than they are of
their own constituents
absolutely so what happens is nancy
pelosi shrieks and her hair stands on
end like she's like floating around like
a banshee
and everyone's just like you know
terrified and then
when ilhan omar does something she calms
down and
well you know let's be reasonable and
republicans are like that's not fair
anyway is that is that it there's no
screech screeching banshees on the
republican side we're going to float
around and scream
so well again it's and by the way this
was this was i i love
president trump but this was a trump
fault you hit the nail on the head too
many republicans care about what the new
york times says about them it's like
trump would be talking to maggie
haberman at the new york times yep and
i'm like
why are you talking to maggie she hates
you pathologically
she despises you she will never write a
good story about you it's
and yet he still would because he wanted
to see that good story it's like sad
cringe
it's like it is these uh these
republicans
are desperate to be accepted by the
establishment political class
so they they bag the new york times i
know you're woke but i'll pretend to be
woke a little bit
not all of them there's a handful of
good ones so we recently saw
thomas massey marjory taylor green they
refused to wear masks
nancy pelosi fined margaret taylor green
500 bucks then 2 500 bucks
yet she's on video in the white house
with no mask on
hugging people and everyone nobody's
wearing master all partying
this is the problem the democrats have
double standards if they didn't have
double standards they have none at all
and the republicans
don't do anything no no absolutely speed
bumps for democrats absolutely
and by the way look when i heard pelosi
give her explanation for why
that she was not going to remove the
mass mandate she said it's you know a
question of the honor system
and am i just going to trust that these
people have gotten vaccinated here's the
thing
you don't have to worry the cdc said if
you've gotten vaccinated
you don't have to worry about
unvaccinated people so here's nancy
pelosi standing there saying
something that contradicts her you know
the science
the science of all these people can be
like we got to follow the science follow
the science
again if trump had said something like
that it would be non-stop coverage for
three days about how trump is ignoring
the science
nancy pelosi says it and the media just
brushes it off there was a study done in
france and uh tech crunch wrote about it
it was this
little-known drug called
hydroxychloroquine and trump just
passively said the study is looking very
great you know it's looking good maybe
we'll see something
and the media went nuts donald trump is
recommending medicine oh
no people are gonna die bro there's
people outside of 7-elevens giving
vaccines and i'm like
hold on man if you're gonna undergo any
kind of medical procedure i'll be at a
minor one like a vaccine
go to your doctor first because you know
i was reading about some kid who had
had an allergic reaction or something or
was like you know was told by his doctor
he'd like be careful i forgot what it
was something with eggs i don't know
and uh there's there's there's a video
where like these army guys walk into
7-eleven and then just like give the guy
behind the counter a vaccine and i'm
like
you were complaining about donald trump
talking about
news from techcrunch and now this is
going on
can't you just say vaccines are great go
talk to your doctor to figure out what's
best for you
they don't do that they they will smear
trump and attack him in the most extreme
ways and claim
trump's had to inject bleach in your
veins and then they'll and then they'll
come out and like
do the exact opposite we don't got
fighters though man
no we don't and by the way we we never
have and
and the only good side of that is that's
how we ended up with trump we ended up
with trump because after decades of not
having fighters
the base said okay who's the one
candidate that they won't they don't
want us to vote for
trump that's that's the guy that they
all hate so we're going to give them
the one guy they say we can't vote for
do you remember the
michael moore speech from 2016 which one
was that
so michael moore's speech he said that
you know donald trump walks into these
auto manufacturers and he says if you
move your cars overseas i will i will
tax you 30 percent
and no one will ever buy your car again
and the people of michigan heard that
and that's the first time anyone ever
stood up to these companies
and so people they saw trump you know
now not paraphrasing that people saw
trump as the biggest fu to the
establishment a human molotov cocktail
be thrown in the system
and he was and the system boy did they
react
they they flipped out look i always tell
people i voted for trump there's a lot
of policy
things that i voted for trump based on
but even bigger than that
i voted for him to be the wrecking ball
taken to the system
like and he accomplished it in spades he
completely and totally exposed the media
he exposed the establishment of the
republican party
he exposed the dirty way that politics
has been played in this country for
decades and decades and decades
and we're never going to go back like
the the base of the republican party
that voted for trump
trump led all the monkeys out of our
cages and they're never going to be able
to put us back again
let's talk about the establishment let's
talk about this story from
the hill so the hill is described by
news guard as an 80 out of 100 in terms
of credibility
they don't regular they don't regularly
collect correct their errors and they
don't disclose their financing but for
the most part they're a
very very reputable outlet fauci
bombshell
not convinced covet 19 developed
naturally outside wuhan lab
interesting i seem to recall a a
president what was his name he was
orange
he had the weird hair donald trump who
said they were investigating this theory
and then um it was it was it was the um
this one paper of of of
merit and repute that says democracy
dies in darkness that claimed over and
over again it was a conspiracy theory
and cnn
and reuters and a bunch of all these
other outlets alluded to or
insinuated or outright said lab leak is
a conspiracy theory
right wing media sites blah blah blah
why
because donald trump said it it was a
story in the washington post i remember
reading
that actually said questions rise about
a potential lab leak
there was a story in the daily mail
which said something similar and then
donald trump had to open his mouth and
the media
they as we were talking about don lemon
they built themselves off of
i can just imagine it you're sitting in
the editorial meeting
it's like so uh it's 9 am and you walk
in and there's president zucker
all right guys what's in the news today
well we got this interesting story about
a
potential
lab league that coven may have come from
a lab really wow
now run with it that's a huge story what
else we got uh donald trump said the lab
like whoa whoa whoa stop he runs out
catches the guys no
no no no don't run that story don't run
that story come back come back to the
meeting then go back in
okay uh donald trump pushed unhinged
conspiracy theory roll it
so all of a sudden stories that were
either based in fact this is the
craziest thing donald trump
would read the news you know ian
crossland does backflip then he'd go out
and be like this guy ian you see him
this ian does a backflip it's amazing
and they'll be like ian does front flip
trump lies
and you're just like what would it what
is this that's what they built
themselves off of
so now we have fauchi i think this is
his what is 10th or 12th flip-flop
fauchi has you could make a video this
is someone should do this if you're
listening someone do this
take all the video clips of fauci
advocating a position
and then put it next to fauci advocating
the opposite position and have him
debate himself
so um later with crowder actually did
that oh he did it together
they beat us to it i know there you go
yeah well
what's what's so amazing is is that it
you know it hasn't just been
you know fouchy i mean kamala harris was
talking about how she wasn't sure
whether she would take the vaccine
that was developed under trump and then
they had the audacity to be talking
about
we've got these vaccine skeptic people
oh really
really you spent the last year telling
people it would be five
ten years before we got a vaccine if it
was before then then it probably was
going to be trustworthy because trump
can't be trusted
now they want people to completely and
totally forget about that and say
you got to go out and you got to get
your vaccine well now they want people
to be drunk
right go to the bar and give them free
beer or in front of a 7-eleven it's like
okay i do find it funny that that a lot
of the people who are opposing the
vaccine were trump supporters or are
trump supporters
and then a lot of people who are getting
it won't give trump credit for doing the
job
to be fair a lot of people always bring
up you can support them producing a
vaccine but still think it should be
a choice like the doctor should decide
yeah but that wasn't but that's not what
they were saying during the
campaign they were saying that trump was
lying to people about getting a vaccine
we were never going to have a vaccine by
january of 2021 we had kamal harris out
there talking about how
who knows it could be safe i'm not sure
whether i would trust and wasn't it
wasn't it biden too like biden kamala
like cuomo
they had all been like i don't know you
gotta wait for the science
i think i think a bunch of democrats
came out and said it oh absolutely i
started tweeting that they were
anti-vaxxers
well but this is essentially their
entire all of their positions were
dictated by
as you pointed out what trump said if
trump had actually come out and said you
want to know what vaccines are going to
be bad
they would have been telling us we're
gonna have a vaccine tomorrow it's gonna
be the greatest thing since sliced bread
like they're everything that they all of
their positions
were premised on whatever donald trump
was for it's by the way
it's why the democratic party has had
this bizarre flip-flop
on suddenly becoming the party of
foreign intervention all over the world
because trump was against foreign
interventionism so
so now bill crystal feels at home in the
new democratic party
i gotta give a shout out to the babylon
bee again because we have this
satirical satirical article article
ingenious move trump supports
impeachment
forcing democrats to oppose
again that really what it was again that
that seems like insane
but it also hits so close to home i mean
so so this vouchy thing about the lab
leak is
in my opinion it shouldn't be news fauci
is a very dumb and dangerous person
he he was the one who for hold on let me
slow down
fauci lied about masks this is a this is
a fact
that fauci has admitted to that early on
he told people not to wear masks
this is this is i love this he then came
out later and said
well you know we wanted people to to not
buy the masks so that
the the medical professionals could have
them why do medical professionals need
masks
why do they why do the medical
professionals need them professionals
need those masks anybody
so they don't breathe pathogens into
open wounds while they're doing surgery
so so because of covet right like they
don't want to pass disease but why do
they need more than they already have
why was it so important
that we get all of these masks not to
the people but to the medical
professionals
so the insinuation is the medical
professionals needed more masks than
usual
right what was happening that was
alarming everybody
that made us think doctors needed more
masks
this is why there was a there was a
pandemic yeah there was a pandemic going
on
now how do you prevent the pandemic you
get regular people to wear masks
so if fauci came out and said you should
all be wearing your masks
right away then the doctors would not
have needed so many
because people wouldn't be dying in
hospitals because they didn't have masks
fauci admitted he wanted the doctors to
have them
because he's a [ __ ] because he doesn't
understand cause and effect
and now all of these people line up as
though his word is gospel let me just
reiterate that
if from the beginning fauci said just
wear a mask
the doctors would not have needed as
many because there would be less
sick people in hospitals he lied
people died and it contributed to the
overwhelming of the system this guy
is a [ __ ] who thinks he's smart and all
he does
is he repeats what the news said but two
days later
i've made that point since since the
mask thing reversal happened i was like
is this guy just coming out and
repeating what he saw on cnn two days
ago
and now here we are again we have this
story about fauci saying
i you know i'm not convinced the virus
you know originated naturally
oh is it because the news broke in the
past few months
that lab leak was a real potential and
now fauci flip-flops
again my favorite my favorite absolute
favorite
fauci is on its show and he gets asked
should people wear double mask 2 masks
and he goes it's just common sense that
if you want to layer and you have to it
would provide more protection
then he goes on another show there's no
data suggesting two masks
is is better and it is not being
recommended and then a few days like 10
days later
the cdc recommends two masks the dude is
so dumb
he is on every side of the debate and he
is responsible for many people in cities
being dead
because he said don't wear masks for a
stupid reason
well and by the way look it's not just
around mass that people ignored the
science that fauci
and our overlords ignored the science i
mean from the very beginning we knew
that that the the survivability rate
from covid was incredibly high
the people who were at most the most at
risk were the elderly and people who had
multiple
comorbidities from the very beginning
our effort should have been to protect
those people
what did cuomo do he put those people in
the worst situation possible said hey
sick let's shove them back into uh
you know rest homes and we'll get other
people sick and more people will die
we we had uh janice dinon ah she's so
good but you know about her
yeah her in-laws yeah she lost both of
her in-laws because uh
i i'm just gonna say i quote cuomo
murdered those people
he was advised this would kill people he
had the option to use the jevit center
or
was it the mercy that he didn't do it
because
he didn't want to help trump of course
absolutely absolutely new york was
new york was struggling and trump being
the executive you know sent
things to new york at the javits center
at the you know with the mercy
that they never used they didn't again
because politics was more important than
people's lives
doesn't this constitute you know there
was this uh princeton professor years
ago said we're in a cold civil war
we refer to it as the culture war but we
refer to it as war because people have
uh well there's cold war and there's hot
war and people have been killed
and there has been a lot of violence but
we're not at a point where it's like a
traditional hot war where there's like
armed factions or anything
but maybe it's because we're becoming
too blind to what conflict actually
looks like
maybe conflict looks like a governor
knowingly putting sick people in nursing
homes killing 15 000 people
maybe warfare looks like democrats
advocating for the secession of the west
coast this is john podesta reported by
the boston globe
if donald trump wins maybe this is the
media
lying maybe this is fouchy flip-flopping
maybe it is
your political leaders willing to let
you die for political power
and it's two different factions there's
a bunch of smaller sub-factions within
the parent factions
unfortunately for those that oppose the
democrats the republicans are
mostly a bunch of jellyfish flopping
around doing nothing so instead
we sit here and watch as cuomo literally
knowingly puts sick people in nursing
homes resulting in fifteen thousand dead
and the dude gets a book deal
and an emmy an enemy he won an emmy
justice
no no and by the way like look this guy
is still like
first off what he did with the the
nursing home scandal is absolutely
unbelievable
you'd think that any decent governor
would resign
how many women now have come out and
claimed
there's no accountability and democrats
learned a long time ago
they don't have to be accountable the
media is not going to
hold them accountable so if the media is
not going to hold them accountable
why should they why should they buy
ralph northam's still the governor
of virginia he's out there you know
terry mccall's out there touting his
endorsement
and this is the guy who is in the either
in blackface or in the kkk outfit
yeah which one i don't think it matters
i think either way the guy's got to get
out of there but they don't care yeah
donald trump
no he's the racist right yes not the guy
not the governor who
you know his nickname in uh undergrad
was [ __ ] man
that was his nickname [ __ ] man and then
by the way you remember after he
admitted that it was him
then 24 hours later he came out and said
actually i've thought about some more i
don't think it actually was me
but there was this other time that i did
blackface but that was just
a party and i'm like is this for real i
was like man this guy's done like 24
hours no
no no no it's tribalism yeah it is
so deeply tribal that socialists have
aligned themselves with the one percent
the wealthy elites
because they hate donald trump it is the
most insane thing
i mean think about it the the occupy
wall street people not all of them
because it kind of split but many of
those activists
are are voting for joe biden i'm like yo
you guys protested that dude i was there
i watched you protest that dude
now you're voting for him well because
trump is worse what
didn't you want to like shake the system
up and challenge the establishment
donald trump is a bull in a china shop
no no trump has bet he's a fascist
whatever man the the these it's been
absolutely ridiculous for me to see
these old activists who protested the
one percent supporting
like the lincoln project david from bill
crystal
like these these republicans are getting
support from from socialists
well and by the way wonderful george w
bush is now
adored by the left and the media
who this was chimpy mchitler remember
yeah like all these people
all these innocent children died in the
middle east because
you know bush wanted a war for oil
apparently that's
all's forgiven now as long as you as
long as you hate trump
all is forgiven and now and now you know
what we're gonna get from
these they're they're you know
i said something about uh democrats
being dumb
on twitter there was a story from msnbc
that said the gop
you know pushes bill to make teaching
the history of slavery
you know illegal or to ban the teaching
of slavery and i'm like
clearly that's not real of course the
actual story is critical race theory
which is an ideology which is not fact
and these people watch msnbc and they
believe it
and that's like you know the q anon
people believe insane things
like i'll tell you absolutely every i
remember like every day after the
election i'd have people being like dude
i'm telling you it's tomorrow tomorrow
come on where you at bro i'm like no no
it's actually tomorrow i'm like
right it's tomorrow permanently but
they're not institutional
they don't have massive power they're
not holding up infrastructure
msnbc is mainstream they're pumping
these
peop these people full of insane lies so
it's a good thing their ratings are
collapsing
but it still leaves us holding this bag
we got this story
from human events breaking from jack
pasok
leaked state department memo indicates
official
support for black lives matter agenda do
you want to know what one of their
agenda items is
disrupting the nuclear family is that
part of the biden administration
i mean the dude's already a racist
according to federal courts right he's
biden this is the this is the craziest
thing the bite administration
has implemented relief pro relief funds
for
restaurants only if you're not white
though if you're right back of the line
so what happened is this one guy sues
the problem
they already gave out billions of
dollars so they have decided
illegally violation of the 1964 civil
rights act and unconstitutionally
to give money on the basis of race
and you can sue them and you can stop
them but they already did it
so what well and by the way biden is the
greatest trojan horse
ever and here's why they got the oldest
whitest guy in the entire world to be
the one who's out there pushing critical
race theory
and official support for black lives
matter because
joe biden's not running this show you
know i mean and
the the scary thing to me is and this
like sounds like such a crazy conspiracy
theorist
the crazy thing to me is like i know
that joe biden's not running this show
and i know kamala harris isn't running
the show so i'm always up with
who's actually making decisions in this
because
there's really insidious stuff that's
happening somebody is being very
effective at their job we just don't
know who it is but
maybe not could it be that joe biden is
so pathetic and weak
that black lives matter stuff can just
waltz right in
yeah but like somebody the way that this
somebody's making these decisions
somebody is saying
at some level institutionally
let's make this part of this i think you
know so the the alternative
it doesn't have to be one person who's
in charge by the way but the the
alternative to the conspiracy theory is
the standalone complex
which is a bunch of people doing the
same thing that looks like a conspiracy
yeah
i really do think that it's not so much
that we're looking at a nucleus and
control
because biden certainly does not exude
nucleus and control
i think we're looking at the opposite a
fracturing
and confusion and the only thing people
know is what's in the news
and the news is woke woke woke so
they're just like
woke i guess and but it's also kind of
like a mexican standoff
so you have a lot of people who probably
hate wokeness but they're scared of
speaking out because they think
they'll get canceled so what you have is
100 people in a room
all going i i'm woke i'm woke but deep
down they're all anti-woke
but they're scared other people are woke
you see what it is
so i don't i don't i don't see it as a
grand conspiracy because it's too
ridiculous and nonsensical well and in a
way
this may be the opposite side of the
coin that trump had when it came to
staffing
trump's number one issue was staffing he
relied on
the establishment think tanks in dc to
fill out his like mid-level and
low-level
political appointees the result was a
whole bunch of people who didn't believe
trump who didn't like trump and who took
it upon themselves to run their own
little fiefdoms
the biden administration the
progressives may have just done a really
great job at making sure their people
are the people who got
hired the people the true believers
ended up there
you know i mean it's not it's not the
rahm emanuel
disciples who are in charge in the biden
administration
i called it i liken it to fire in that
it's just an expansion
expansive chaotic and destructive force
that once it grabs onto something that
can fuel its fire it does
so it's fairly random and it's spreading
into the military it's spreading into
the state department to the federal
reserve which is like one of the
weirdest stories
do we have that yeah we have that one
right here look at this senate
republicans expand investigation into
woke
mission creep of federal reserve now
that is the scariest thing because i'll
tell you i'll tell you one thing and ian
ian
he knows this you can complain about the
government being woke and we can argue
about it oh this is bad when the federal
reserve gets woke
then i started i'm getting worried
makes me think that it is intentional i
keep thinking about the great reset
and the bank of international
settlements which basically oversees the
federal reserve the bank of england the
bank of australia
and like it's it's not a no government
has any oversight of what these
organizations are doing the great reset
has blatantly said that they want to
i don't know how you describe it but
destroy the economic order and reinstill
a new world where we own nothing and
that we're all kind of
subservient and everything's given to us
on loan by some
some greater that like just is popping
on and off i don't know if that matters
ian you will own nothing and you will be
happy well i hope that that's not the
case but dear lord
uh and it seems like they're showing
dissent within the united
states to break it up because the
greatest resistance is
this liberty that we've got i just don't
think it's a conspiracy
i think it's there's no more strong
leaders
there's no more social and moral
cohesion and so
it's i i i don't think there's a strong
powerful cabal of people that want to
break it apart i think it's a bunch of
people
grabbing you know money from the vault
as the building's on fire
i i would refer to that time magazine
article that
specifically people that are
intentionally
see what the media does i'll say this
much
my colleague brent hammerscheck at uh
human events wrote a really awesome
article about how we're now all
dissidents the conservatives were
dissidents and
he's got this great thing where
everybody always talks about like well
there's
more of us than them who cares that
there's more of us
than them because they control all of
the the levers of power
in this country big businesses run by
the left
academia is run by the left pop culture
is run by the left like
they they're in control of everything so
it doesn't take a conspiracy theory what
it takes is
is it takes a handful it takes a group
of people
who are all thinking the same way who
also happen to occupy
the most powerful positions in the
country i mean
we always talk about like fox news
that's great we have like one
fox news compare what the and fox news
does great
but compare like what fox news news's
viewership is
to what all the other left-wing media
outlets are
and then you realize fox looks like this
and all of the left-wing organizations
look like
that i mean it is it's a it is
i think we've been lulled into this
sense of believing that because there's
more of
us than them that that somehow is going
to save us and it's
not so ian's certainly not a
conservative
and not really sometimes depends on the
situation i don't i don't think there's
a sane argument for saying you're a
conservative
i can certainly say you have libertarian
overlapping
the death penalty that's kind of a
conservative yeah
for sure i'm hardcore when it comes to
military discipline and stuff
wow i didn't realize the hip ian hippie
guy was like kill them all
the authoritarian out tim um i don't
know i i'm just
i don't think of myself as liberal or
i'm both liberal
in certain situations which need it and
conservative when we want conservation
and and
to maintain and retain my point is uh
conservatives certainly call me
left-wing but left-wings call me
conservative because
obviously i'm kind of in the middle and
so the conservatives actually have
allies with disaffected liberals and
moderates liberal people who have
actually watched the news surprise
surprise end up joining like
the likes of the intellectual dark web
or becoming fans of it but most of these
people
just watch msnbc now here's the problem
there may be more of us on the freedom
and individualism side than the
constructivism collectivism side
however if we got a hundred people on
this side
of which 20 have spines and they have
40 people on that side of which 30 have
spines
they're going to win those battles over
and over and over again i i can't tell
you how many celebrities i've talked to
who are like well actually i can't
probably like 10 or 12
who are like i you know i believe
everything you say i'm a big fan of the
show but i can't speak up because i'll
lose everything and i'm like then you
don't deserve
anything correct you get to you get to
what you're saying is
when you tell me this guys when you call
me you tell me this
you're telling me that you're okay
extracting value from the system
to live lavishly because let's be real
you guys are rich
you're not suffering like the average
american and you won't give up your
silver spoon to save your own country
fine and you don't deserve it and what
what what's what what is anyone going to
do
because they'll certainly wield the
power and i don't not only do the left
of celebrities will the power
but even leftist celebrities who also
don't like it
will just toe the line if it means cash
into bank yeah and also afraid that
they'll come for them
i mean look look at how many times that
the the left has eaten one of their own
they'll they'll do it you know i mean
the
the the the they have no problem
sacrificing one of their own
if it means it keeps a hundred more of
them in line
man it's like who would want to be part
of the borg you know the metaphor i keep
thinking is the russian
world war ii the russians and the
germans and there were
so many more russians as far as i know
but
and there were so much fewer germans but
they had better technology
whereas you see these people on the left
have access to the media they have the
better technology they have the
the tanks the blitz creek and then all
these other people
are are you know technologically maybe
in less less empowered
the russians only won that war well it's
complicated but they were allies
external allies and they also won by war
of attrition
by this by destroying what they love
burning their own courts
yeah exactly i mean they could suffer
the most losses in the war so it's not
it's the zep bran against strategy
that sending wave after a wave of your
own men until
you just overrun the enemy they were
like mass-produced trash tanks
the the communist method was really just
let the people die
just just mowing people into it the the
capitalist and american strategy was
have the efficient machine have the
efficient strategy so we have air
superiority and nuclear bombs that means
we minimize the risk to ourselves the
communists
load them all up and send them out and
just sacrifice wave after waiting
they didn't they didn't compare just
grind them all up just grind them all
out it worked so it did
it's not pretty for only for only some
amount of time certain amount of time
yeah it may not be a good metaphor
because if
if the people on the right were the the
communi it's just this ridiculous
outside of the box metaphor but like the
cancel culture thing of just like
keep going with it keep saying what
might get you banned online and then
they keep
one by one taking these people out it's
just i think
i think this metaphor is not good well
it's only it's only
thanks for bearing with it that was fun
yeah it's only a matter of time
uh because they control the institutions
until
everybody's been so what you crashed the
code the allies cracked the code that
gave them some
google facebook twitter they are slowly
making excuses to purge people and they
have
it's this is what happens when you have
a religion
that is violent oppressive and extreme
christians aren't that and you know the
nazis violent
excessive extreme actually ate
themselves from the inside out
as you can see this left us doing they
tried to kill hitler like their own the
own
people tried to murder him and that
basically drove hitler insane and then
made him make
start making poor decisions of
leadership it's extremists and then they
fell apart
as a so you could see maybe see that
happening to this
wokeness too i could see that they i
mean they obviously go after each other
like you were saying earlier
and i mean i really do it's one i'm not
always the most optimistic guy about
this stuff like i think politically
in the short term i think we're gonna i
think we're gonna feel the pain
for a while and even if republicans win
back the house and the senate
i have no i don't know i have no faith
in these people none at all so
yeah but long term i do feel like that
this like woke
like push is going to undermine
democrats because again like i said
until we pass my amendment to outlaw
suburban women from being able to
vote like they they matter and this this
critical race theory stopped being until
then
right this critical race theory stuff
that's being pushed in public schools
like this is the type of stuff and
democrats are starting to warn liberal
thinkers are starting to warn democrats
you've got a lot of problems here you've
got prop like you
are going to disaffect that base that
you just relied on to get elected
by pushing this critical race theory
stuff you run around teaching that this
country is fundamentally
a racist country that it's you know that
we're still a fundamentally racist
country that we're founded on racism
it's not simply teaching yes slavery was
terrible and the lessons learned from
that and
jim crow was terrible but that somehow
we're beyond saving
this country is just garbage it's really
i got a really simple solution for
everybody
if you work for one of these companies
or you are a member of a school board or
you have kids in one of these schools
and you hear critical critical theory in
general
file a complaint with the appropriate
administration or organization so
uh if you work for a company and they
announce they're doing critical race
theory trainings
or if another employee brings up
critical race theory
report them for racial harassment
immediately i'm not exaggerating
you go to your boss and say janet came
and started spouting a bunch of racist
stuff
and i demand you tell her to stop
otherwise i will file a complaint you
have been warned
and then you know what they'll do
they'll say janet stop the racist stuff
and she go i was arguing against her i
don't care what it is
stop it right these people are getting
mad that's why you have to use their own
language against that
that's why when whenever i see somebody
like talking about critical race theory
like yes you accuse them of being racist
because that's what they are but that's
but it's i won't do it though they're
like
critical race theory is it's a kind of
bad thing it's like you know like
rather than saying like this is racist
if you work for a company here i'll tell
you what i would do because we talked
about this last week if i worked for a
company and the boss was like we're
doing a racial sensitivity training
i would be like oh this is going to be
great and i would go in and no matter
what
they say i would get offended if there
was there was a training video i guess i
think
i think this was was from coke or
something i remember i heard this but
someone was talking to me about
in the training it explained racial
stereotypes it was like people often
think latinos are lazy and said a bunch
of things
unlike if you're latino you should
immediately say excuse me
did we just get invited to your clan
rally so you can explain to people
why people think latinos are lazy and
then they'll have to shut it down
here's how it works you give your boss a
warning and if they don't
rectify the problem then you inform them
you're filing a complaint with the equal
employment opportunity commission i
think it's called eeoc
and then you go and file the complaint
now again i've mentioned this before
maybe someone at the administration at
the eoc is going to be super welcome to
tell you go screw yourself and that's
where starts getting bad
but for the time being he's going and
you don't even got to be specific
you don't got to be listen if there was
a guy and
he's a boss and he's like a white
progressive guy and he's like we're
going to be doing you know critical race
theory diversity training i'd be like if
you do that i will be filing a complaint
and then when i file the complaint i'll
say he started spouting a bunch of
extremely racist sentiments talking
about how some people of certain races
were inherently bad or wrong and it was
bad to look this way and have this
colored skin
what did he say specifically i can't
repeat it don't make me say it
that's it go to the boss go above your
go go above your boss and say
he said a bunch of racist things what
did he say i will not repeat it but i
have warned you he is harassing and is
racist
people need to do this because guess
what it's not about using the language
of the left
it's about you could be sitting there
and being like man that that
that chris rock's a funny guy excuse me
and then they go and complain about
cultural appropriation
and then your boss is gonna be like you
really gotta chill out on the racist
stuff you're like wait what i didn't say
anything
well they complained about you being
racist so
if they bring it up complain about it
the problem is our side has
traditionally sucked at this
you know i mean because by the way
because most of us just want to be left
alone
you know we just want to do our own
thing like fine you have opinions
i i don't really like them whatever it
doesn't change my life
but you're right we can no longer just
sit back and let that
happen and because the fact that we've
allowed ourselves to be
rolled over to the point where it's not
okay we're we're not allowed to have
opinions anymore that that they don't
like
uh if you're not willing to fight back
you know i agree
you know you know what really bothers me
i i go through i go through like
uh uh some phases when i watch bullying
right
so i see a kid getting bullied and the
first thing i get mad about is the bully
leave that dude alone what's wrong with
you and then after
like the tenth time you know i get mad
at the kid getting bullied you know why
bro at a certain point you've got to
change what's happening you can't keep
walking up to the bully stop walking
this direction
stop going to the school or stand up for
yourself
but at a certain point if you don't
stand up for yourself after all of this
i won't defend you
i'll get mad i'll say you're on your own
and so i've talked about this with
police
like the cops in in in the minneapolis
area they're getting defunded in
brooklyn center and you know what i'm
not going to defend them sorry
i defended him before the election what
did we see in philadelphia they're
experiencing one of the worst crime
surges ever
so they re-elect in a landslide their
progressive soft on crime
d.a well let's keep doing our fire
hot but let's try it again maybe fire
not hot this time
i'm i'm not gonna defend the people of
philadelphia i'm not gonna defend those
cops if they stick around and they get
locked up for you know trying to arrest
somebody
and look at first i'm gonna be like
these people burning on these cities are
awful they're bad they must be stopped
then i watch in a landslide victory the
democrats vote in the politicians who
supported the riots and i'm like okay
it's all yours
have a nice day yeah let no let the rich
white people experience
what they they bought it you know they
paid for it let them have it
like you you look if that's if that's
what you want and but none of them
actually want that
right none of them want that but because
they're all living in their states and
they're in the nice areas of town and
they're like
they're they think they're immune from
this but you know what's happening now
wall street general reported
the areas that have experienced the
worst sergeant crime black neighborhoods
latino neighborhoods of course not
affecting the white progressive suburbs
no so take away their cops take them
they want to abolish the police you get
what you ask for because i'll tell you
what
i live in the middle of nowhere you know
we got guns we're good
uh i'd prefer if it wouldn't have to be
this way but if they're advocating for
abolishing the police i'm gonna take
responsibility for myself
but going back to the stuff about
critical theory it's not just race
there's critical gender theory it's
critical theory
as a whole which is this marxist
philosophy frankfurt school etc
it's really really simple you see a
flyer on the wall that says
white privilege or anything like that
you immediately file an anonymous
complaint about racial harassment from
the individual who put it up
don't don't you don't gotta get specific
you can say they were spouting racist
things
disparaging people on the base of their
race it's a violation of the 1964 civil
rights act
and i'm upset about i think it's title
vii and if they don't rectify it
you can file a complaint and they will
get in trouble
in new york it's particularly serious if
you live in new york
city it's a 250
000 fine if they do not stop this
behavior
so you warn your boss say you work at
starbucks and they're like we're gonna
have to talk about white privilege no
you're not because if you say one more
word
i will file a complaint for racial
harassment they'll be like uh
uh say it i told you not to harass me
and then go file a complaint and say
they were making
you know harassing people base of the
race saying some employees were better
than others on the basis of their race
some were worse than others boom 250k
out of their pocket that's not even
using their own tactics
that's just the law and it's a law that
today
the 1964 civil rights act basically
everybody agrees with
it should be illegal to discriminate on
the basis of race except for the woke
left
nobody's fighting though yeah but by the
way i'm i'm 100 for using their own
tactics
but right like i'm i i look i wish we
lived in a place where the you know
cancer culture didn't exist but as long
as cancer culture exists then i'm for
cancelling
liberals i see this on twitter all the
time when people are like stop
celebrating this person got fired
because they had this
position no i'm going to celebrate every
single time one of theirs goes down i'm
going to celebrate
because again this is a war of attrition
and until they start feeling some of the
pain
they're not going to change the policies
aren't going to change they're not going
to change what they're doing
until enough of them start feeling the
pain of it
no i i don't think that's i don't think
that's going to work
they sacrifice their own they cancel
their own they do but eventually
look eventually it's going to start and
we we've seen it a little bit
you know when there'd be the like you
know recently the woman who was the
hamas
terrorist supporter the 8th yeah at ap
who lost their job and they're like you
know all these reporters are like this
is so terrible that somebody can't have
their own
opinion blah blah blah it's like where
were you guys like every
any conservative in the entire world
gets fired for having you know
objectional opinions
this woman is actually a supporter of
terrorism and you're angry that she lost
her
her job could have sworn marjorie taylor
green got stripped over committees for
things she said years before she got
elected
yes amazing yeah amazing how that is but
again like
let them feel the pain from it you know
uh i'm in favor of cancelers getting
cancelled
but i'm not in favor of leftists getting
canceled for their opinions
because there's got to be a standard if
if if this is a leftist
who is actively trying to get people
fired and then they get fired i will
laugh
and say get out of here i'm not going to
help you yeah you're nuts it's like the
fire being put out by a controlled burn
we're happy about it
but if it's just some like you know dumb
commie twitter account who says
something communist so they ban them
that's bad
that's really bad there's got to be a
line as so anybody who's for free speech
i'll protect their right to free speech
anybody who's not well then
you don't want my support anyway but the
problem is is that all of these people
are for cancer culture themselves
i'm saying if there is somebody who is
like pro free speech yeah
i mean unfortunately those people don't
exist on the left anymore and there's
there's a little bit
there's a decent amount uh she went
ahead you know she's for free speech
so i will absolutely defend her at every
turn for her right to speak
and say what she wants to say uh i'll
i'll defend hel tulsi gabbard
oh there you go but tulsi is like she's
got more spine than most republicans on
this stuff
i know which is which is embarrassing by
the way it's absolutely embarrassing
that the like the the progressive
democrat tulsi gabbard
yeah she's progressive she's for gun
control she's for socialized medicine
yeah i mean she she's not conservative
but again i think this is where
some of the breakdowns on the political
partisan battles these days
aren't on these like traditional left
right axis
you know it's not like it's a whole
bunch of are you pro-life are you
pro-choice are you pro this pro
like some of this stuff really is
crossing all of those lines
and and for us to win we need more of
the tulsi gabbard's we need more of the
tulsi gabbard saying like
you know what this is ridiculous like
lori lightfoot in chicago saying she's
only going to
give interviews to to reporters of color
like
can you can you name a republican who's
called out the anti-white racism
from a politician ever i can't i don't
think so
no yeah i don't think so tulsi gabbard
said this is anti-white racism and
she should resign it should be condemned
everyone should come together and it's
like
yeah chelsea we know but they're not you
know they're not no one's playing fair
no they're like the republicans aren't
playing at all they're sitting on their
hands and the democrats are just trying
to burn it down
right well and by the way like again
this is because democrats when they get
power are willing to use you know every
every tool available to them and our
side
won't which is why i said like if we
went back to the house and senate i have
no faith
i think of it like this like you vote
you're like there's a bank
and you vote for the the democrats
because they're promising to run
you know when we're in the bank
everyone's going to get a higher
interest rate you're all going to get 10
percentage
wow and then as soon as they get in you
just watch them like going into the
vault and carrying out stacks of cash
and you're like where are you where are
you going
what's it what are you doing and then
you're like you know what
i'm going to vote for the republican
next time because these people are just
taking money from the vault
then you vote for republicans and
they're just like sitting on the on the
toilet on their phones and you can't
find them you're like what's going on
like the democrats are still
looting the vault and then they're all
just all in the bathroom on their phones
because they don't actually do their
jobs so who do you vote for
i i i feel like it really does feel
like it's on purpose but i think the
reality is
the democrats are just looting the vault
you vote for them and they run in
and they grab as much as they can and
they run out they sign bills that
guarantee their future
they're extracting the system and it's
getting worse so my friends i bring you
to the ever
ever uh uh the never-ending story how
about that
of san francisco i remember the first
time i heard about san francisco's poop
patrol
do you know about san francisco's poop
patrol yeah so they like you know some
cities have a fire department
everybody's got a fire department maybe
you've got a volunteer fire department
you're living up on a mountain or
something
maybe you got to you've got a local
police department or sheriff's
department san francisco has a poop
department
it is a publicly funded poop unit that
goes around with specialized tools for
cleaning up human waste
because their streets are littered with
it the new york times reports
san francisco's shoplifting surge the
mundane crime of shoplifting has spun
out of control in san francisco forcing
some chain stores to close i believe it
was what 17
walgreens stores because the police said
they're no longer going to arrest people
for these petty crimes
you see a video of these women in
walgreens and they're just shoveling
makeup products cosmetics into bags
because the cops won't come
they're not going to bother with it
anymore the democrats said the police
system is oppressive
let's not have it
and so you don't well so in new york
apparently
there was a a series of shoplifting
things that were happening
so more of like the cbs cbs and
walgreens were starting to put more
stuff behind lock and key
and cynthia nixon being the great
limousine liberal that she is
tweeted out about how she went to her
corner cvs and she saw stuff
behind lock and key and she was so
offended at this time that people were
struggling
to make ends meet that they thought that
this was the best way to handle it i
mean
that's that that that's why like when
people say liberalism is disorder i'm
like that's so not nice to say and i'm
like
actually but it may be a disorder but we
can't let them take the word liberalism
because that's certainly not what it is
i know but like the the
the idea that you see you see things
behind lock and key in a cvs
and and and instead of thinking about
isn't this terrible that we are we have
the scourge of shoplifting to the point
that shop owners are required to put
stuff behind lock and key
instead you think isn't it awful at this
time when people are struggling to eat
that people feel like they have to hide
things
this is this is the cycle of democrats
here's what happens
someone shoplifts and get arrested and
gets arrested
and then people outside are filming and
the person screaming my hands you're
hurting me i can't breathe and they're
like this is bad he was only shoplifting
like this is
crazy like what are these cops doing so
then they all protest they smash a bunch
of windows and they burn places down
and the city says people people we've
heard your cries
we will no longer arrest shoplifters
then all of a sudden
and this is actually what happens
walgreens sees a wave of shoplifting
and so then walgreens puts things behind
locked cages
and then people start filming it going
walgreens is racist
they are racist because the only things
that they're covering up
are the products used by minority
communities it's like
but there's no cops to stop the
shoplifting so they have to lock the
products up now
now you're complaining about what you
advocated for
that's the system they say we must
abolish the police because the police
are oppressive
then crime skyrockets see the police
weren't doing anything anyway they
weren't keeping our community safe
no no you got rid of the cops you
defunded them you abolished them what
are you complaining about now
the left is completely predicated on
building coalitions of victims
so all their policies have to be geared
towards creating
new victims no one can ever graduate
from
victimhood it's why like look gay people
for years and years and years said we
get the right to marry the right to open
you know openly serve the military like
our work here is going to be done
when they said actually now it's lgbtq
a plus right two because you can't no
one's ever
allowed to leave you're never allowed to
graduate out of victim the fact is is
the gay people in this country
have more freedoms than anybody any any
other country in the entire planet
they've been the most successful civil
rights movement of
all time in record time people should be
high-fiving
instead you've got the left trying to
convince them
that you know actually you're still
oppressed
my favorite uh article i think is from
the root it said
black men are the white people of black
people yeah
like something like that and it was like
wait what they needed
to find some kind of power dynamic the
the woke left
so it's not it's not all of them but
they do align behind this
they only believe that there is no truth
but power
so that that was a that was a a
fascistic ideology that the only thing
that mattered was power
because truth is irrelevant if if you
could remove anyone who believed the
truth
the left doesn't believe in objective
reality then i mean the
like overall there are obviously
obviously some leftists who are like
andy woke communists but doesn't matter
because they still vote for biden who
then puts in woke policy
they they don't believe in objective
reality they do believe in power
dynamics
they literally follow tenets of fascism
now i know they're not ultra-right
nationalists so
spare me left us and you're like that's
the truth they are authoritarian
race-based identitarian generalized
identitarian
and they have fascistic tendencies call
it whatever you want i don't care
they're psychopaths
well it's like the the the left is also
years ago
the left decided to adopt this politics
of intersectionality
where you had to be for everybody else's
agenda
the right has always been this coalition
of kind of diverse like
i'm the gun people and the abortion
people and they can agree on this and
disagree on that
and it's it's always been you know this
kind of raucous
coalition of folks the left decided a
long time ago that they had to stamp out
any opposition to each other everyone
you you couldn't just be
like i'm the pro-choice democrat you
also had to be
i'm the pro everything else and you had
to be at 100
percent and that's why they've been so
effective
is because they've made like what what
does you know the human rights campaign
it's the largest lgbt organization
in the country takes all kinds of
positions on crap that have absolutely
nothing to do with gay people whatsoever
because the left has been so effective
at intersectional politics you have to
buy in on everything well this is the
example i love to give is an
organization called free press free
press.net
what do you think an organization called
freepress.net advocates for us in
nonprofit
sounds like freedom of the press so
would you be surprised at all to learn
that they advocated for the censorship
of alex jones
wow i remember when i saw that i know
people there and i hit them up i'm like
why are you guys advocating for
censorship
like hate speech is bad i'm like isn't
that just press
like i don't get it what's the
difference between your opinion and
their opinion well their hate speech i'm
like
free press it doesn't say free press for
some
i guess that's what that's it changed
they changed intersectionality
all of a sudden you had to support all
of the causes yep even if it defied your
own principles principles were gone
and then i love it i love it i had a
meeting with some people from vice
and they're like dude i don't know man
like people change
you know it's like they that stuff
doesn't fly and i was like bro
do you think maybe you changed and then
these these two people were like
yeah yeah there was an article in vice
about uh
an app that you take a picture of a
woman and then it uses
ai to show her topless and they called
it like this
horrible app shows a women woman topless
and then i was like you see that article
i was like do you know what vice would
have titled that article in 2012
this amazing yeah it shows you women
tablets
because it was meant to be in your face
edgy angry
something happened to vice where they
became feminists
and that's when they were like yeah
you're right
but we can't do that anymore it's like
of course you can you just you just
you're scared like why can't you do it
your ratings are in the gutter your
views are in the gutter
clearly people liked the punk rock fu
attitude
and what did you give them instead
demure scared
feminism yeah that's exactly what's
going to save your company
now they're in the gutter that the
disney wrote off their 500 million
whatever investment advice to zero
congratulations getting woke was it
worth it
well because it won't go broke
everything it's
same thing's happened in comedy you know
i mean comedy has been absolutely ruined
by
the woke left you know and it's why the
handful of people
who your push back against wilker
actually like some of the most
powerful activists in this country which
is so
crazy i mean at its base like comedy was
supposed to be funny it was supposed to
be equal
opportunity offenders pick on everybody
like slaughter
all the sacred cows yeah instead you
watch like
late night you know tv over the last
four or five years they're telling the
same joke on every channel every night
snl is unwatchable from start to finish
and it has been
because the number one point of comedy
was to make people laugh and instead
they decided the number one point had to
be to toe
clapter it's called clapter it's where
people aren't laughing at the jokes
they're clapping because they agree with
the political message right so these
comedy shows during the trump era like
snl
they would get alec baldwin to do this
impression that in
no way resembled trump it was the
weirdest thing like trump wouldn't ever
just
freeze and then hold his mouth open in a
weird way it didn't happen
so alex like alec baldwin was just
making fun of the guy
like he wasn't doing an impression it
was just people laughing because they
hated trump
there was no substance there was no
humor well i shouldn't say there's no
humor
if you find it funny fine but it was
clapter they would get a guy on stage
it'd be like trump is so dumb and then
everyone go and they'll laugh and clap
at each other and it's like
okay well you look at all the other late
night hosts and it's all the exact same
thing and john oliver is like the worst
that guy just like lies all the time
it's it's hilarious how awful the show
is
it's formulaic little timothy over here
says trump is bad and everyone laughs
and i'm like what's funny about that
well i mean that's the thing though is
that like i mean
i would love if by the way if alec
baldwin had actually done
a good trump impression i would have
laughed yeah the impression he did
actually got worse as it went along
he wasn't doing an impression no it was
like the same thing and again
like i laughed all the time i enjoy
comedy that makes fun
of everybody there's plenty of things to
make fun of trump about that could have
been
funny but it never was because it was it
was all about the political it was all
about trying to get the
the clap the applause line it's like
after the hillary clinton
loss you know when the the snl did the
skit with
you know the woman coming out and you
know it's hillary and like singing the
song
and it was like what am i watching
about this we got this art on the wall
you can't you can't you guys can't see
it in the cameras but
it's from george alex opolis and it's uh
one part of a comic about trump
it's trump struggling to eat what
appears to be like broccoli and he can't
he's wearing a bib it says bib boy in
the original comic he says like my hands
are too small and he's struggling to eat
it
what's funny about this is it's not
really making fun of trump
it's making fun of the left as they
would make fun of trump
so when when i look at it i laugh but
i'm not laughing because trump has a
little hands and wears a bib
i'm laughing because that's the the
garbage joke the left hand is the only
thing they had you turn on family guy
trump was orange literally massively fat
with tiny little hands and i'm like
who are you talking to right trump
doesn't have little hands i get the joke
the first time but is that
it that was it that was it they were
just there it is it is like
a bunch of drones all being with the
applause sign flashing that's what tiny
hands was they'd go
hey hey ian in tiny hands oh
that's like okay that's not i get it
whatever
apparently joe comedy's crushing it in
texas right now the the creek in the
cave are you familiar
with that is that rogans well no it was
uh independent thing run by
rebecca out in new york and they shut
down because of covid
and reopened in austin and now they're
out yeah nice i keep here it's
apparently one of the hottest spots in
austin right now
awesome yeah but you do have some people
who are willing to say fu and kind of
push the body because ryan long
obviously we've had on the show several
times
it's just good luck getting it on
network tv that's that's the problem no
no i don't i don't
i don't think these people want that
anymore i think the comedians are like
why you can't make jokes i mean what's
his name
uh got arrested for talk for george
carlin yeah carla got arrested for talk
saying that's
awesome eight words you can't say seven
words you can't say and you set them
anyway and then so like that
does not jive with late night tv it's
it's always kind of cool
to to land like a tonight show spot as a
comedian but
i think like you said about the
republicans seeking like the new uh
a good word in the new york times like
getting an award or getting that one
moment in the spotlight is not really
it's not really like the counterculture
has become the establishment
like i'm literally sitting there
listening to siriusxm and and the
rage against the machine tom morello
came on talking about his like channel
and blah blah blah and i was like
like rage against the machine is now
rage for the machine rage on behalf of
the machine yeah like i'm like this is
it's the least like right now
like all of these people have completely
sold out everything that they were
supposedly
all the counter culture and punk rock
and all that it's all dead
they killed it all it's all just milk
toast boring crap now
you know it's like tom morello was like
what's up everybody this is tom morello
from rage against the machine
check out my album you can order it on
amazon or find it at walmart
produced by shenzhen slave labor
youth 30 cents a big problem with the
record music industry is like
auto tune and computers like how you can
you can record your
one tr one like uh segment of like uh
one what do they call it a beat or like
uh yeah
you know you can like 16 bars you can
record it and then stop
and then record the next 16 bars and
then cut them together in the computer
which is totally disjointed what are you
talking about if you want to like sing a
song
normally back in the day what does that
have to do with where you were it's
cheap into the art
you know
not even talking about the same thing if
you know when when hip-hop came out
people called them
demo tapes they said it was not real
music i'm not gonna have an argument
what is or isn't enjoyable music
i'm having an argument about punk rock
bands that are supporting walmart and
amazon yeah well you can't be punk if
you're gonna rely on a computer to do
that yes you can dude
it's not punk rock dude punk rock's
great old mannion
get with the program i'm not even
thrilled punk rock is
is hard core it's not you don't rely on
a machine to fix it for you
you're making excuses for your bad music
i'm pointing out why you can make music
with whatever you want to make music
you know you know it's amazing to
digress but on the music thing here
sean ono lennon is like one of the best
follows
on he is and like i'm like then the guy
is not even saying anything that's that
far out there
he's just asking questions sometimes and
i'm realizing that's revolutionary right
now on the left
somebody who's john lennon john lennon's
son with yoko ono
like so he's got these kind of like the
background that's bulletproof you can't
accuse sean o'neal lennon
of being like a white nationalist so
he's the guy who can say like hey by the
way
have are things going too far and start
asking the question and i'm like
that's so crazy that we've gotten to a
point where that's revolutionary
that's that's actually revolutionary is
now doing something
so yeah baby step of just saying
hey is this going too far i should i
should just write parody punk music
that's just like super in favor of the
establishment and like massive
multinational corporations
just write a punk rock song like joe
biden rocks i can't even go
i can't so i used to like rages machine
but i can't even listen to their music
anymore
because all of it feels so fraudulent at
this point yeah i mean
to be fair like killing in the name like
have there was a video i saw was funny
was conservatives dancing to
killing in the name and i'm like you
guys know that songs about like
white supremacist cops who are murdering
black people like that's black lives
matter
i guess the interesting thing is the
response i saw from this i tweeted about
it were people like dude they know what
the song's about
like they legit don't like cops who are
racists killing black people
the left just thinks all conservatives
agree with that and i'm like wow that's
actually kind of a crazy point
like you could have liked rage against
the machine and then
and then i i had this funny moment where
i was talking to zantifa guy
this was in berkeley and he had a knife
and he was like all those people are
fascists and i was like all
those people in in in the park right
over there like yeah they're all
fascists man and i was like do you think
those people are pro-gun
and he's like yeah and i was like do you
know why they're pro-gun
he's like i don't know i was like isn't
it because they're scared of a
tyrannical government taking over so
they want guns to protect themselves
from
fascism and he was like
oh yeah i guess and i'm like so it kind
of sounds like they're the ones who
don't like fascism and they like
want guns to protect themselves see like
the left has this assumption that
the right loves the government and i'm
like yeah maybe some elements are like
supportive of the government
but like the gadsden flag and like all
that stuff about like small government
i'm not surprised they're dancing to
rage against the machine
where they're preaching about racist
cops like being bad
because conservatives are also skeptical
of government but they do support cops
that's why it was kind of paradise so in
a way i feel like kind of the bases have
kind of flipped over the last
20 years with the the the base of the
the
right-wing base getting more and more
like skeptical
of authority skeptical of the government
more like self-reliant
you you're less interested in foreign
adventurism
you're less you know you're more
skeptical of wall street and big
business and
the the left has completely and totally
sold out to all of that again
gets your point about rage against
machines selling their you know their
seats i don't know walmart
actually but they probably are i'm sure
they are but
like they've sold all of that out the
the
occupy wall street people are now the
party of
wall street well occupy wall street
split up so
a decent amount of those people became
trump supporters i remember i went to
the deplorable
in dc and i was just like i'm like i
didn't think anybody there would know
who i was and i saw two people and they
were like tim
huge fans thank like so cool to see you
here nice to meet you and i was like oh
i didn't realize
i'd have fans who are like trump
supporters and they're like oh no we
were down at occupy wall street the
whole time
i was like you're wearing maga hats like
yeah yeah trump's the guy man and i was
like wow
but like when you think about it these
are people who are angry at the banking
establishment angry at the political
establishment
and donald trump came in and said bring
the jobs back secure the borders
that sounds about right but also they
were voting against hillary we got to be
honest
hillary usurped that from bernie and uh
people voted against hillary just like
they voted against trump this time they
voted against
hillary clinton that nasty woman if she
was just so hateable
if she just she was yeah
you know in a way that like biden is
really not that hateful
he's just kind of you know and you
almost feel bad for him you feel like
god i wish
i wish he wasn't she without this over
with yeah like you know yeah
you know how the story ends hurry up and
get to the end of the story like where's
like hillary every time she said
something
it came across as so smarmy and so
elitist and you're just like
oh god i want you to lose so bad
please lose her email scandal was insane
like that what she burned like ten
thousand thirty thousand emails that she
just destroyed and disrupted with like
talks with sydney blumenthal about going
into libya
and when she was secretary of state
she's got after she was she was showing
titles
she said she said it was yoga it was
emails about yoga yeah
no doubt yeah her daughter's wedding
yeah it's like
i just again she was the perfect
opponent for
trump yeah because it was the
establishment
versus you know i'm not the first person
to say this but it was
you know it was bushwood yeah it was
rodney dangerfield
it was the you know it was the
caddyshack you know have you ever seen
dogma
no you don't see the movie dogma have
you seen dogma you guys haven't seen the
movie dog
what the kevin smith first kevin smith
movie i missed with jane simon bob and
like basically the story is
loki and what was the other the other
angel
bartleby two angels fell from heaven
they want to go back
man i can't believe you guys haven't
seen the movie anyway there's a point in
the movie
where this demon his name is asriel he
wants to end
all existence because he hates being in
hell and so
there's one scene where he summons or
like
yeah something called the golgothan it's
a demon
made of human excrement so golgotha i
guess i'm i don't know this is where
they uh crucified people right right and
so when people get crucified all their
wastes
you know like drops out and so the idea
was that all that waste from
all these evil people formed a demon
called the golgothan
hillary clinton is that but for the
political elites so like after a a huge
really long congressional session and
all of the members of congress and
senate run to the bathrooms and then
flush at the same time
hillary emerges from that from that muck
and climbs out
yeah and then she goes up on stage vote
for me
you're like i'll take the orange guy
right ladies
you know outside of the silliness she
represented all of the
filth of the political establishment
more so than anyone we'd seen in a
really long
and she never even tried to shine it up
that was the thing that was so amazing
about hillary it was like i mean look
bill was garbage i mean he was total
trash but bill
tried to come across as i feel you're
pine you know
he tried to be likable like well hillary
figured out a long time ago like i'm
completely unlikable so i'm just gonna
go with it
you know who would you rather vote for
mitt romney or hillary clinton
oh geez i mean i guess hillary clinton
really yeah you want to know why because
i think maybe she would like at least
keep us
safe internationally you know like she's
going to start with
war with russia i know look that's i
don't know i feel like the worst thing
that romney would do was just
extract value from the system and watch
it fall apart hillary would actively get
us involved in conflicts but it
probably would too i guess i guess the
question is would you vote for the same
person that's probably
not a good analogy they're both just so
awful yeah they're both terrible
yeah and by the way it's another thing
we talk about things that trump has
exposed
trump exposed people like mitt romney
you know like
and it's it's so it's so beautiful the
guy who was the 2012 nominee of the
republican party
is getting booed in his home state by
republican delegates
because they hate the guy and you know
what the truth is is that mitt romney
has always hated his own voters
he has always hated the dirty unwashed
masses that he had to rely on
and like it's it's so gorgeous to
finally see people waking up to the fact
that you want to know what he never
liked you
yeah he hated your guts paul ryan did
too none of these people liked you
you know it's you know it's really funny
like hillary clinton definitely doesn't
like you
and they say i see these memes on the
left we're like trump doesn't like you
he's using you and i'm like have you
ever seen trump interact with people
i've been at trump rallies you know what
the man does he hugs and like shakes
hands and he like smiles and he's a
germaphobe
it's like the craziest thing when he
walks over and he's saying autographs
from people he would do a rally and he
would come down
and he would meet and greet people have
long conversations with them
i go to i went to trump tower i went to
the ice cream shop
and i asked and the steakhouse and asked
the employees like you guys ever see
trump down here and they're like yeah
every so often
do you like them they're like he's great
he like walks over and just hands you
100
bill it's awesome and i'm like wow they
really like the guy hillary clinton you
want the stories we hear about her
she's on like an air force jet and she
holds her wine glass up goes
and these like air force officers are
like lady i'm not getting your wine for
you and she just
[Music]
had to pour her wine for her the stories
about hillary are that she's despicable
and evil and nasty and then you look
before donald trump ran for president
everybody loved them
oh god yeah they love the guy yep
absolutely and by the way so 2011
i got trump invited to speak at his
first cpac
uh and trump comes and he's a total mess
before his
speech he's mad it was late like he
went to the wrong entrance it was kind
of a disaster
he goes up there gives a barn burner
speech he gets done we're walking out
and they decide they want
to leave through the service entrance so
we're going out the service entrance
and literally he stopped and shook hands
with and took his picture
with every single busboy
waiter housekeeper like every i was
it was the first time like i watched him
give a speech and it was like it was
trump being trump you know and i was
like
i never didn't think it was like trump
had some political future
and then i watched him interact with all
of those working-class people on the way
out
and i was like wait a second like there
actually may be something here
yeah well how about we go to super chats
everybody
if you haven't already smash that like
button it really does help subscribe to
this channel
and share the show with your friends the
best thing you can do
and uh if you're listening on itunes or
spotify give us a good review
smash the like button let's read it so a
lot of people have mentioned we have bad
audio
we'll we'll we'll sort it through
tweaking it yeah we're tweaking it we're
gonna listen back and then
just try to make it better and better
and better it's you know you can do what
you do i guess you know
all right let's see xeon reborn says
texas passed
three pro 2a bills and it's on the way
to the governor's desk
constitutional carry suppressor freedom
and two-way sanctuary state
wow do we got to move to texas i
second that i like the weather i do not
like the weather
i do not like the weather either no
bring it on the impressive heat
maybe maybe we can buy an old missile
silence and live underground
there's like and everything will kill
you there yeah scorpion snakes like yeah
it's like a mini australia yeah i'm not
good with that
florida and texas are passing these laws
that are really good
for uh social media censorship you know
the weather
but the weather florida's the worst i
know no i so i was at uh trump doral
like
at the end of march beginning of april
and it was like
nice time to be in miami which meant it
was like 90. ugh yeah so i'm like i'm
not built for this
and it's yeah it's humid it is maximum
humidity and maximum heat
so people can't go outside and say
because you can't so people stay inside
of the air conditioning
when i lived in miami we were just like
oh man i can't wait till january and
february when we can actually go outside
brutal even then it's 90 in february or
something but it wasn't as humid yeah
so it was like you could go outside and
it was just hot but you were still okay
how nice yeah yeah and the rest of the
year was like maximum humidity so
you like swim through the air it's like
but the thunderstorms are really fun
you know watching the crazy storms and
by the way like i'll give
like obviously florida handled covid
like said
when i went down there it was still
where florida was free america
so the just the joy of taking off my
mask and not like
i was like i can deal with the heat i
can deal with the humidity this
is the way life is supposed to be lived
all right we got
kyle buchanan says the babylon bee must
be shut down because too many of their
stories come
true that's right
georgie georgev says hello tim i'm an
alcoholic you helped me while i recover
i watched all your stuff love you man i
make good money i hate how the msm lies
i have a friend that thinks you are far
right he refuses to listen and be
rational
anyway love you man it's like what does
far right even mean you know
like we're just an approximation of a
chimpanzee full of snakes
that's right yeah that's right go watch
freedom tunes if you don't understand
what that reference is
just kidding says released my first
independent ep today still alive by
jason card
on youtube and band camp support
non-woke musicians
absolutely very cool
caleb crowe says have you heard the
recent song never take it by 21 pilots
a bit surprised they took the issue on
thought you'd find it interesting
starts out quote now that they know
information is just a currency and
nothing more
interesting bullet tooth tony says
malice at 26 on amazon for anarchist
handbook
is it 26 i thought it was super super
high under anarchy
as like general i think he is number 26
in general
which i guess is like above oprah and
definitely nice job michael
everybody you need to buy michael's book
the anarchist handbook
on on amazon you must because we have to
support people who are challenging the
cathedral and the establishment
and no one uh well i shouldn't say no
one but michael is one of the best of
the best so
it doesn't does it with such glee
it never like it never feels mean it
always just feels so good
he's like um he's like an undercover
angel
yeah he's cool he's really
he gets way too much promotion on the
show we're always just singing his
praises
he also involved in our lifestyle this
book so he's like really wrong no but
i've
people should buy his book because uh
and and and michael knowles
the book is available for pre oh i heard
oh that looks speechless
gotta support people who are challenging
the establishment navas says
when let alone if is tim cast going to
sell raffle off
tim cast live tickets okay um there are
several things that have to be done
on a business level which are very
difficult to do we literally can't just
be like come hang out you can't do it
it's not not allowed
for a variety of reasons so appropriate
legal paperwork to allow us to
have people you know come new website
launches
we're going to have first come first
serve select tickets
we need to figure out what the total
capacity is going to be it might
actually be 30 so it might be 15 and 15
and then we're going to have auction
based tickets of the top 15 in the
auction we'll get the tickets at a
certain you know so
like it'll go on for 24 hours and then
when it finishes it'll go boom there's
the people who win the tickets
and that way we can have the people who
maybe you know can't afford to pay crazy
amount for tickets
first come first serve that's unmerit if
you can get it you can log in fast
enough you can get it
and then for the people who are too busy
with work can just choose to pay a
little bit more we're trying to find the
right balance
it's basically just about screening you
know people we don't i don't expect to
make
a billion dollars off of tickets we're
just trying to find a way to do it
appropriately because we don't have that
much space
but um we wanted to do it in march
and then we hit legal bump where it's
like no no no no you can't do that
it's like okay well we got to file
paperwork and then once we can
yeah and then we got to build the
website so i think the website should be
done in only a few more weeks
the final upgrade with you know it's
like we're upgrading our upgrades
we're building as fast we can it's only
been four and a half months ladies and
gentlemen since we launched the website
so please
bear with us if you are a member at
timcast.com just know that you being a
member
is what's allowing us to actually fix
and make this good so my apologies to
everybody's experience some kind of bug
or glitch or something
we built like a really simple wordpress
site and then
we got traffic on par with like a large
news publication that we weren't
prepared for because we did not expect
that's our fault that's our fault for
sure but i really do appreciate
everybody helping
that setup butters scott stotch says
have you ever thought about having donut
operator on your show i think he would
be great
donut operator has an open invitation
absolutely
i i guess we got just got to figure out
when we can and colleen noir as well
xerma's playground says amazon is now
implementing vaccine ids for their
employees
in order to remove your mask you have to
bring in proof of vaccination and get a
sticker on your id even in florida
they're flagrantly disregarding the
passport ban i'm so glad i'm leaving
well you see this is a clever loophole
they're not saying you must or or you're
out they're saying
no you don't have to but you can take
your mask off if you do see how that
works
it's clever it's kind of like how the
government bans guns they say
we're not banning the gun but it is now
an nfa item
which means you'll have to pay a tax and
then file paperwork and then get
fingerprinted and then maybe a year
you'll be able to get it and a lot of
people just go
i don't want it it's too much work
michael k says about calling biden
policies communist nazi
you are forgetting that nazi is an
abbreviation of national nationalist
socialist
merlin suffered coal shortages in 1937
german was second largest producer of
coal after usa
interesting yes communist nazis
commander michelan says in the book
version of starship troopers service is
anything meant to serve your fellow man
most being government services like like
mail road construction etc
and the gov cannot deny you from serving
i like that
simulation says community service
guarantees the right to vote 50 hours of
community service for the right to vote
that year
i don't know what do you think about
that i kind of like it gotta define
community service
because like you know you're an artist
and you perform shows and people love
you and you help and you do it free
then that would be a type of community
service but you go to
government doesn't think like what if i
don't like leaving my mountain i just
want to be left alone up there
if you don't want to contribute you got
you don't have skin in the game why
should you get to
vote on what people do with their money
or their tax dollars because they take
my money in tax dollars
i guess that's that's a good argument
against citizen service guaranteeing
citizenship
if you pay you vote so how about that i
work
and then i give money to the system so i
have a right to say what that money goes
to it's fair
so so then you get a bunch of really
dumb people with no skin in the game
other than their taxes
hey there you go oh here we go josiah
magnuson says project veritas dropped a
video with whistleblowers talking about
facebook suppression of vaccine
hesitancy on their site
karibi wow oh james o'keefe by the way
got cast in off-broadway performance was
it oklahoma
playing currently wow that's awesome
nice job james
i'm excited i think you know the problem
is i'm like man james o'keefe needs to
run for office
because he's a fighter do you see him
doing the moon walk yeah
i've seen him doing many moon walks he's
awesome but he's probably the
most james has got like so many spines
he's probably have to go for surgery to
like fix his back
like his his spine is too big it's too
big he belongs he
he fights harder and more than basically
anybody else smart too
but then is it like is he more effective
running veritas than he would be in
office
probably he's going the right direction
with the with the
entertainment industry i think he just
likes singing and dancing true for sure
he does like the michael jackson stuff
he's funny he's so
serious with his work with veritas but
he's so funny it's always so fun
learning like little bits about people
like that that you're like god that's so
against type i love you you saw the
music video that they did no what was it
called
i forget it's kind of like a batman like
a paul abdul video oligarchy
oh yeah yeah yeah filmed a music video
called oligarchy
excellent doc williams says tim long
time listener
thank you and guests for making people
aware to prepare for the unraveling
i work my fingers to the bone to turn
money into food crypto and various fast
metals
my family is ready i love cassie and our
three girls oh
you know i don't know what's gonna
happen uh i'm i've got one foot
in one foot out in terms of like
actually thinking something crazy bad is
gonna happen and there's gonna be a
collapse or whatever
and what i mean by that is you know are
we going to go full
mad max probably not is there going to
be turmoil
probably turmoil happens and we've been
in a really long period of growth
and golden age now things are getting
crazier so it's not like i think the us
will cease to exist you know a lot of
people are like the country's going to
break up until like
the the chinese run west and the
european union and canada and mexico and
like the john teter conspiracy and i'm
like
i think the dollar will bottom out and
the petrol dollar will cease to be the
main thing maybe and then we'll have to
spend a lot more money and work harder
for food and we'll all probably just
keep living
yeah we desperately need a new industry
in the united states i think that
something like the graphene industry
could could absolutely
be this we could be the 25 years
familiar with graphene the material it's
carbon
like a carbon nano lattice or one layer
it's it's
incredible incredible uh chemical
properties it's like electrically
conductive
you could use it as a super capacitive
battery you could use it as wallpaper
clothing you can eat it it's pure carbon
and if the united states can start
industrializing and printing this stuff
and selling it to the world
i think that can give us a purpose by
the way i i'm not one who thinks that
like things are just going to completely
fall apart i do have to tell you
the the shutdown of the pipeline for a
week yeah was a real eye-opener to me
because a whole bunch of people who i
didn't think would be the type who were
going to panic
panicked started pouring gas in their
pockets yeah like you saw yeah
and by the way it wasn't just out in
like you know my rural
area like dc had no gas yeah 88 percent
of stations were out
yeah that's crazy so it's like i feel
like the country is on edge
yep james orenthal new yen
says two of your youngest fans lola and
seyuli
would love a would love a shout out from
everyone on tonight's show
they also want to know if the tim cast
events will be general admission
or bar age patrons only i believe
it will be general admission uh
we do a family-friendly show and the
events we're planning on doing are going
to be just kind of like hangouts with
maybe some music
maybe we'll have you know a certain
guest to come and we'll
hang out you get to just you know
probably grill some late night burgers
or something and it's it's going to be
like the idea would be
a friday at 10 to midnight you come you
hang out play music there's drinks
and it's super chill so people will be
there probably with their kids and stuff
like that
and we'll have to figure it out because
there's a capacity issue
but if like someone gets a ticket and
they want to come with their family but
their family
it's it's tough right if some someone
buys a ticket and then their wife
doesn't what are we going to say like
your family can't come we'll have to
figure it out so there's a lot of stuff
to work through
but uh i think you know one ticket
probably should be good for like
for you know a family whatever we'll
figure it out the big issue is
capacity issues so we have legal things
to deal with in terms of a business
allowing people to come
and then it's not that big of an outdoor
space so
the initial number i think was like 20
people so that should accommodate if
people have like family and kids were
coming so it'd be like 30 or 40 people
max so we can only sell like 20 tickets
we got to figure it out
mr renegade says i'm a truck driver
who's a giant fan of
oh actually i forgot um can you guys
shout out lola and
say uli yeah lola and seyuli lola
say willy what up they sound adorable
i'd love to meet them
there you go shout out okay mr renegade
says i'm a truck driver who's a giant
fan of the show
and i appreciate all the work you guys
do my favorite line that tim
used to say is the screeching and
reading left bring it back
i yeah you know i'm trying to like
differentiate between the different
groups because liberals and leftists are
not the same thing i can respect
that leftists are like we demand gun
rights and i'm like that's good
i don't think for the same reason as us
but if you want to defend my right to
bear arms
in general i'm going to accept that win
liberals don't want to do that
so you got to like figure out the
different factions so like the
screeching and reading left these like
the woke ones who have no real politics
but just scream because they're just
whiny you know like the dsa meeting
where they were like put a personal
privilege um
chattering is is getting to me and yeah
that's perpetually aggrieved
yes perpetually aggrieved
all right axel thunderpaw says we're in
a civil war
and a cultural revolution our elites are
killing citizens and stealing their
money and rights
hopefully youtube actually lets me super
chat for once and
uh cuomo put sick people knowingly in
nursing homes
and killed people creepy
dragon lady says democrats move from
blue area to red
destroy it and move on they're like
locusts they're moving from planet to
planet
after they've consumed every natural
resource they move on independence day
brandon tom says fauci lied people died
as missing one key premise
idiots listen to him the proverb proverb
for me once shame on you
shouldn't be taken seriously during a
pandemic we're endowed with our own
minds to discern evidence and prosper
in the beginning when fauci said don't
wear a mask this was early on and i was
like i like the guy you know he says you
don't need it so it makes sense it's not
going to do all that much i think people
are freaking out it's not going to
protect you
and then it turns out he lied and i took
him seriously and i won't
i won't make that same mistake and i
mean he was like nah this guy's lying
he's full of it
he just sits in his room and he's
probably like eating cheetos with like
cheeto dust on his hands and he's
watching msnbc and they're like should
we wear two masks and he goes two
minutes
i like that oh i gotta go on tv in an
hour you should wear two masks
um he never actually said to wear two
mess he was just like asked and he's
like it's common sense they're wearing
two masks
there you go cal al says wokeness is
being driven by
feeding hr and corporations with fake
data made by ai
and bots on what's popular from twitter
and social media on what's popular
fifty to eighty percent of opinions are
fake i completely agree
james alford says chris barron never
heard of him but i like him
thanks tim for opening me up to people i
can respect and sometimes disagree with
and yes that can be one of your hosts
absolutely
joshua reiman says to paraphrase al
pacino scent of a woman
for the fed reserve and deep state fu2
hey there you go matthew
mansfield says ian is a grey jedi yeah
you're right
you can see it brand dizzle says the
killbots had a preset amount of kills
registered in their system
zap clearly outsmarted the coding he did
you know that reference from feature
elmo
so zap brannigan is this really bad
military leader for some reason
and it was a war against the killbots
and he's like i quickly realized the
killbots had a preset kill limit
so i sent wave after wave of my own men
until the limit was met and then the war
was over
yeah that's one way to do it a preset
kill limit
what a great show anthony catherine said
did ian just admit to being a jellyfish
i'm a libertarian when we need it and a
conservative when needed read this
after his answer um i highly recommend
looking at pictures of the brain
stem inside your body because it looks
like a jellyfish
he's confessed and then anthony says
nothing
i hope he is a contrarian he is that
obviously
i don't think so okay
zendo kian says hit like g d
it that's right you must hit like smash
the like button
clef the misfit says tim you're giving
people bad advice proponents of crt
don't use the term
people need to look at for the words
diversity equity inclusion
intersectionality social justice and
racism i don't like the term critical
race theory because it cuts out the rest
of critical theory
but i will tell you a lot of people say
i wonder how it is that in world war ii
it got so bad that people would go along
with like
doing the salutes to hitler the roman
salute and stuff why would they do that
have you looked outside of one of these
protests where these people are marching
around doing the red salute
do you know what the red salute is it's
the communist salute it's where i'm not
gonna do it
you raise your fist up oh and hold it
straight up showing your fingers
and the difference is there's showing
your fist to someone
which is like a threat or you know an
assertion of your power
the reason the red salute displays the
fingers is that each finger together
is weak each finger is weak but together
it makes a strong fist and you're
showing the people
the unity it's very similar to the
fascists where they had the bundle of
sticks
was the was it called the fascists the
weapon
and so they would hold that shows all
the sticks together make a powerful and
it was very very similar
i saw a photo of someone in my own
family doing the red salute
it would be no different if you saw them
doing the the roman soldiers yes
yep but how many people have you seen
marching and doing the fists in the air
wasn't that bad
also yeah yeah and the white power
salute sure call whatever you want
raising your fist in the air and and the
white power salute is raising your hand
in the air right
i don't care what you want to call it if
the communists have a red salute
and some racial group adopts that symbol
they can call it whatever they want the
swastika is a nazi symbol i don't care
what the what ancient
it's like an ancient hindu symbol matter
to me anymore it's now people don't look
at that and say oh yeah ancient hinduism
wheel of time no they go i know what
that is
so now the problem is people are showing
the the red salute which is the fist
and they go oh black lives matter it was
very very clever to use the communist
symbol
but to change its name because now they
have the same symbol
representing the same ideology the
berlin wall was called the anti-fascist
protection rampart
antifa is not new it is literal
communism
they are authoritarians and americans
are not educated on this
so we all know why nazis are bad but too
many americans don't realize they're
marching around doing
what is effectively the same salute but
the opposing group
right the communist nazis fought the
communists lost in germany the nazis won
that was the fight now they're marching
around doing the other extremist faction
salute don't know it
so if you want to know how they how they
got to that point look at what's
happening right now
nadia shall worry no more says i agree
suburban suburban women shouldn't vote
they shouldn't drive either so i don't
have to worry
every day about getting hit i'm not a
small lady how can these people act like
they can't see me
yikes i agree as well
n l sponsor says in honor of tonight's
and every other night's
theme of the deceitful media let me
shill my new album
sponsal from zenith to nadir for the
sake of making culture and all i made
sure i snuck a reference to the rabble
in there for tim's sake
very good so i i love two phrases the
poor's
and the rabble when i'm mocking wealthy
elites
mocking poor people so i love the pores
the pores the pores yeah
you could hear hillary saying i know
right that's so bad for the pores
no no she wouldn't say she feels bad for
them she would go ugh the pores are
trying to get into the debate hall
remember when they had her go into a
chipotle
tipped off the new york times like look
how hillary's so normal she's going to
chipotle
you know they had to like you can do it
you can do it madam secretary and she's
like
i think i can i think i can we'll get
all the pores out it'll be okay
the pores they're looking at me ponyboy
says hey ian have you ever heard of the
adam and eve story by chan thomas
it was a book written in the 1960s and
then classified by the caa
and recently declassified with over 150
pages redacted
yeah i have but only like very vaguely
i remember ah something something like a
man i don't want to misrepresent this
thing
i recommend looking into it it was like
to say i classified it but it was like
some ancient story it was very weird
huh it's got a brutal eyelash it's
killing me wicked
stabbed in the eye yep eric allen says
thank you for giving actionable items to
viewers
eeoc complaints i think the eeoc is the
right uh organization
when like your companies being racist
you complain of them
h music 197 to say ian the beatles used
multiple takes spliced together for
their albums do some research
dude the beatles would like sit down
with uh they
hit record on their on their tape or
whatever they're recording a track
and then they just sing stream of
consciousness they wrote like strawberry
fields in like five minutes or eight
minutes
then they listen back to it this is a
great way that i i make music too
uh i don't know what i don't know much
about their recordings you were talking
about computers remember
yeah yeah i don't think they had
computers didn't they do it on tape
no you're talking about how in computers
you can take chunks and then just line
them up yeah i'm not into that style
that's how they always
i've always disconnected from the music
you want to go back to the 50s where
they would have the band in a big room
and
record well the foo fighters do that now
yeah it's just it's just
i want to be exactly like when i see
them live i don't want i want you to be
able to replicate what i'm listening to
in the album
yeah that's fair oh youtube i love when
they just jump and flood us
yeah the beatles didn't play live they
were a purely a record
making band after their first couple
albums first few albums i know that
megan stewart says the updated audio
makes you guys sound sexy yes it's low
but the quality is good
love you guys keep it the great work
well then we will just figure out how to
boost the audio
yes we'll figure it out there's like
literally a switch the problem is
i don't want to just crank the audio up
right now so we'll have to just do more
tests we did some tests it sounded fine
maybe we'll just do some more it'll be
fine
magic space viking says hey tim and gang
texas resident here the weather you feel
is just the freedom you're feeling
oh yes
carl johnson says third time does it
send you a book called the servile state
would love to hear your opinion on it
when it comes greeting from portland
oregon oh from behind enemy lines
greetings
choice with music says i'm sorry choice
truth music says alanis morissette was
god in dogma feminist lol hey there you
go
explain nation said did you see that 1.6
trillion barrels of oil was discovered
in namibia
africa recently sounds like the us is
going to discover weapons of mass
destruction in namibia
recently oh no protect that oil
let's see machismo joe
chris r baron just because you said it i
asked you about the spin doctors on
twitter now you can't say no one has
ever asked great show
there you go thanks i appreciate it do
you have in your bio not the spin
doctor's guide
no maybe i'll need to put that in now
babysitting yeah
supra says the metal community are a
bunch of clowns they showed their true
colors last year by supporting the soy
ninjas and burn loot murder
not really excited to go to concerts
anymore yeah oof i guess they suck now
yeah that's too bad dolomite access for
once i have to agree with ian i'm a
musician
back in the day music was real and from
the heart now it's all modified like
photos and photoshop
it all sounds the same as well it's junk
you for uh you for one shouldn't
disagree
there's there's always been pop music
there's always been
corporate regurgitated formulaic trash
if someone can take two spoons and clank
them together and make music with it
i dig it if someone can take a bunch of
hard drives
and then have them do different pitches
and write a song with it i dig it if
someone can go on a computer
and type in code that makes music i dig
it if a big corporation
creates an algorithm that manufactures a
song based on all the other songs and
it's a top 40 richard piece of garbage i
don't like it
garbage pop music by corporations who
are like you know we'll use a machine to
make everything sound like everything
else
daniel garland says tim speaking of
texas will you do a
timmy and what is this a timmy and timmy
power hour
with the one and only tim dillon yes or
yes much love from oregon
hopefully elsewhere soon tim dillon is
always welcome on the show but the issue
with people who have their own shows is
that they're busy doing their own shows
rainforest says what's more reliable
source of info tim's joke
post babylon b satire post or cnn's
actual post
yikes probably my joke posts because
they're like
so there was one where there's a video
of the cops telling the protesters the
capital they're allowed to do it
they're like they're you're okay to do
it just do this a lot of people
mentioned the doors were sealed so they
actually opened the doors for people you
can see the videos of it
and so i was like these cops should be
arrested for for treason because they
ate it and abed and insurrection
come on where's the democrats they
should be arresting each one of these
cops
no they're not going to do it so it's
not you know i'm not being serious but
it's
you know more truthful in cnn geraldo
aloe vera says what i've heard texas
oppressor bill is for texas made cans
but its legitimacy is debatable
considering wickard v filburn
as the issue the bill will be interstate
commerce not gun rights
interesting soul invictus says you
forgot the part where the government
levels
guns in our heads to get us to work for
free yeah
they do that
anthony moody says i love you guys do
you think the left will ever open their
eyes to the corruption and destruction
that these politicians are creating
i don't know what do you think i don't
know
i mean i i honestly i again i think back
to like the occupy wall street
and even some of like the bernie like
true believers and i feel like there was
an opportunity
at some point for some of this like
left-right populist to kind of come
together
but i don't know it feels it feels like
they
all of that leftist populism is gone and
it's been replaced by this woke stuff
and i feel like
that's never we're never going there
there's no
there's no common ground with the woke
police
but the regular people who are just
marching and doing the red salute
if you speak up then they will back off
so
the issue is coca-cola comes out and
they yell woke woke and the
conservatives just go hmm that's dumb
and the left cheers so coke's got no
downside
the conservatives don't do anything and
the left is leaving us alone
when when the if coke comes out and says
no no we're not woke
the conservatives do nothing and the
left throws bricks at them
there's the only upside for these
corporations is to support the wokeness
if conservatives start boycotting
legitimately hardcore boycotting being
like
i will never buy from you again they'll
feel the pain and they'll apologize
and by the way it works it works we saw
it with the nfl
we saw it with the nfl the nfl leaned in
so hard on all the kneeling and the woke
and the kaepernick
and the ratings were garbage and they
carried about one thing
money and so all of a sudden a couple
weeks into the of last year
we didn't see anything more it's about
the
blm about send an email what's
who's a company right now disney yeah
disney oh god disney
lost a lot of money year over year but
uh maybe there's a better example
who just recently started pushing woke
trash i can't think i think
there's a cereal company that's doing
super woke cereal boxes
no no i mean like a major corporation
that is just getting political for no
reason
why american airlines american airlines
yeah mass send emails complain
send emails i'm complaining i'm
complaining i'm planning whenever you
see a company do something woke
make sure you send your email and tell
all your friends and family do the same
thing
because when they get flooded with a
hundred thousand emails they'll be like
whoa
we gotta back off this these people are
getting mad at us but conservatives
don't do that
so the only emails they ever get is
you're racist they say we're sorry
if the conservatives are nothing but a
speed bump the corporations don't care
you got to be more than a speed bump yep
you got to be actual opposition
all right let's just just uh let's do a
couple more
george d says tim you can't compare
texas to australia texas doesn't have
enough danger compared to australia
australia our cute cuddly drop barrels
will ruin your day
jonathan duggar says the good news is
once we hit rock bottom there's only one
direction to go
but uh hopefully i mean how much worse
will it get before we know
right yeah if you study the roman the
fall of the roman republic it can get a
lot worse than rock bottom and yeah and
by the way
there's always another bottom like i
keep keep thinking with the media
like okay it's not got this it can't get
worse than this this is gonna be this
moment of introspection and reflection
and
we're gonna get a better media no they
always double down on what the you know
it's like over and over again so
i don't know i don't know what rock
bottom actually looks like yeah
well man well i'm ready for it i hope
you guys are too so make sure
you smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and share the show with
your friends
you can follow us on instagram we post a
bunch of clips every day little clips
from the
from the show uh it's instagram at tim
cast irl and on facebook
facebook.com tim cast iron any of the
same posts but you can share them
and then we can leverage the network of
all of you so that we can get more
people to to go to teamcast.com become
members
and then start getting better
information and break away from the
broken fractured fake news of the
mainstream press
and i'll tell you this my friends with
your membership
we will not be buying infinity pools we
will not be
buying private jets you don't want to do
we're going to be buying journalists
real ones
we're going to be buying documentary
crews to go and film real news
and that's what we want to produce we i
i don't want to be
i don't want to make content that's like
super conservative or liberal i just
want to make
honest content and be like man you guys
decide i don't want to tell you how to
live i'm going to tell you what i saw
we need more of that so when you become
a member at timcast.com that's the kind
of thing you're supporting
you can also get access to these
exclusive members only segments so go to
timkes.com because we'll have an
exclusive segment coming up
they usually go up around 11 p.m so
check it out then
did you want to shout anything out chris
just follow me on twitter chris r barron
there you go and you can follow me at
ian crossland.net at ian crossland um
all over the internet so thanks for
coming guys and you guys are cordially
invited
to join me in my journey to have more
followers on twitter than sour patch
kids
sour patch lids lyds we will see all of
you
over at timcast.com with uh for our
exclusive members only segment thanks
for hanging out we'll see you there
you